[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yeah are
you going to complain about the light
[__] right man look how dark that is
back there this is how Jenny set it up
yeah it's it's too dark I don't think so
I can fix it I can fix it I can fix it
it's only like one or two clicks up does
your dad have a whole bunch of tools my
dad's got a whole foot dud I could fix
it I could fix it fcking SPI I mean yeah
in case you guys didn't see Fast Times
at richmont high that is what we were
referring to you thank you very much so
I could fix it I could fix it no they
couldn't fix it that [__] car was
totally well OB well that was the that
was the joke Tom obviously you couldn't
fix was [__] told see look how pretty
that is now see I like it darker back
then no now we got a little bit of red
back there okay all right I kind of like
it a little bit darker because you can
see the Scully thing
now you can see the [__] curtains and
how classy that [__] is it's all satanic
looking back there yeah yeah okay
today we were pregaming at the Oasis a
little bit the yeah the biker [__]
biker bar our friend Melissa and her
boyfriend uh came down and uh yeah Danny
I think is Dan yeah they were going they
were going to biketoberfest in Daytona
Beach yeah so they they Hometown yeah so
they swung by our local biker bar to
come hang out for a little bit we
haven't haven't seen uh Melissa in years
I don't remember the last time we seen
her I think with the last time we saw
her was at iar probably like a couple
years ago four years ago maybe yeah
maybe maybe it's that long ago it might
have been it might have been but yeah I
haven't seen her in a really long time
so Tom was just going to go down and I
was like well hey um I had a get out of
the house I had a job interview today
but then it was over by then and I was
like I'll come down there and meet you
I'm not going to ride on the back of the
bike but I was like I'll drive down
there yeah and meet you guys yeah so I
let her boyfriend ride my bu he liked it
he let me ride his [__] Harley mhm
souped up [__] Harley it's pretty
pretty nice I couldn't get my foot
underneath the damn shifter though where
he had it adjusted he had it adjusted
for little girl shoes I had my [__]
boots on I had to [__] reach down
sideways and just pull up now you know
why I have why I like to drive in bare
feet yeah it was it was a souped up bike
it was a souped up bike yeah it was a
Dina of some kind naked Dina I think um
2020 I think I think he said did he say
2020 I think he said could hear 2020
y'all were talking I I probably heard
maybe 20% of what you're were saying
maybe not even that much like you know
120 horsepower and like a [__] 100
foot pounds of torque something foot
pounds of torque but it's a 600lb bite
but still it was kind of fun to ride it
was like riding a damn easy easy boy
recliner down the [__]
Street my feet were forward just odd for
me I like the idea of that just getting
in the lazy boy yeah it's like right
Lazy Boy
reclin you know it it was actually
turned pretty well turned pretty sharp
I'm thinking about getting one
be good to have at my age it just looks
more right I
think you you're the old guy it had like
eight hangers I'm looking around like
that people looking at him yeah yeah I
was just wearing this too I had a helmet
on though yeah I mean you had all your
armor from before bet you left it in the
yeah I had I had I just threw the helmet
on I had to watch over it while they
were out doing Shenanigans yeah I had to
sit there in the bar and watch
everybody's drinks yeah it was only 10
minutes though J 10 J's like you guys
are in those B it was only 10 minutes
it's like I'm sitting here with all
these normies horrible country music
yeah it seemed probably seemed like a
long time to you it does seem like a l
it was only like 10 minutes it seems
interminable actually um Danny ring said
Tom have you ever ridden a Ducati yes an
old one well actually a couple of them
uh Ducati Monster 900 I wrode one of
those no excuse me I think it was the I
think it was the the 1100 think it was
Ducati Monster 1100 um somebody offered
me a 900 I never bought it and the other
one was an old [__] Ducati desmo I
think it was desmo desmo Sidi I think is
what it was called this was like a very
late 80s early 90s bike that was a
trip yeah um that was a long time ago
though I couldn't really tell you much
about it other than it was [__]
really odd and [__] shifted really
shitty but it might have been just that
bike but the monster rode a lot better
but the Ducatis are everywhere here in
uh in Florida
that's kind of
like top of the line that's kind of like
a more top of the line in terms of just
reputation top of the line sport bike
guy
motorcycle um now there's a guy that
hangs out at the Oasis who has three
davils three Ducati diil and I think
he's got another one he's a rich guy a
rich old fat guy who he could ride
pretty well but he just you just look at
him you would never think one of those
[__] deatti diil he had was the
Lamborghini Edition which is I think an
80 $90,000 motorcycle he's got one oh
he's Rich he's Rich um yeah it was a it
was the lambo Edition
diil had gold trim on it and [__] it's
it's pretty nice fast fast fast and
Powerful uh but and you couldn't buy
that it had to be offered to you and
they offered it to them you had to be
like a prior top level customer and that
that's all he buys is
Ducatis oh so he's like special yeah
yeah I got you and he's just a dude in
his [__] late 50s early 60s who has a
[__] ton of money and kind of a little
butter ball of estrogen you know I was
like dude man you all these high
performers motorcycles weren't you on
test man [__] you know [__] he's
like why do I care I got money yeah he's
like he's like nah I'm good and you know
I said and I said your wife would be
awful happy goes no I'm single yeah and
I'm going oh okay he plays the escorts
he don't give a [__] that's what I mean
so why should he care yeah if he wants
to get laid he just buys it right yeah
much easier yeah so they're probably not
worried about it yeah but I don't
understand that I mean even one of the
richest men's in the world [__] Jeff
Bezos is [__] on all kinds he looks
great now he used to I think it more
depends on the person I don't even know
but like I said I can see how you having
like a [__] ton of money would just be
like I'm just gon to yeah they take the
easy way out you know well yeah that was
one the reason why wouldn't they I don't
like Jeff ba Bezos too much as business
practices I think he's a [__] uh
tyrannical oligarch that probably just
wants to run everything like a medieval
Lord but at least he's a [__] man had
all that [__] money he came from a
dweebish background I mean I see
pictures of that dude at [__] 35 or
40 just a [__] dweeb you know and now
he's [__] got that [__] ton of
money and he's got dripping with [__]
hot women and he doesn't put he's not
putting these women through the [__]
shore of having to [__] this nasty old
he looks good man he looks good uh that
woman he's with I think is a fitness
trainer she's like a eight you know
she's probably like 40 something she's
not a spring chick she's just an old
older chick within his age range who's
[__] stacked and you know well I do
have a dude that's older and Rich and
actually goes after a woman in his age
range that's that's a that's refreshing
yeah and she's fine isn't it and yeah
she's fine I mean yeah she's hot but at
least she's not like [__] 19 well
they got a lot of dudes that are like
that though and she's hot in his age R
he looks like [__] no he looks great he
looks great he's fuing on he's on gear
he's working out I think I think she is
his personal trainer I think and that
maybe that's how they met I don't really
know that much about yeah I don't know
I've seen pictures of him in his yacht
and that hottie and [__] and [__]
he's looking good for his age he looks
good even for anybody's age and um and
he'd be sitting up on the front of that
[__] yacht in a whole [__] center
of a herum of all these [__] hotties
and [__] and he's at least fitting you
know what I mean yeah he's not some
dweeb or some [__] Butterball he
looks like a man sitting there so I
respect where everybody is just kind of
like well he bought all those chicks
obviously yeah no but the thing is you
look you look at him and he could have
earned them that's what I'm saying it's
like you know yeah he's trying to be the
full package he's not putting those
women through hell because a rich dude
could well yeah because they have a [__]
ton of money [__] down to my a fat I
don't really want to [__] this dude but
yeah right I'm gonna have to money yeah
you know and he's like he's and he's
going to give me $20,000 yeah and he's
like [__] the average one that's like
that is like Baron Vladimir har Conan
come here you know fat [__]
flying fat man like Su with boils all
yeah boils and [__] suck me you know
he's like I got money I don't I don't
need to do [__] yeah that's the wrong
with wrong thinking very wrong thinking
if you have money you should have more
responsibility you know what I mean I
agree there's more responsibility your
standards should be even
higher I agree because now you have to
compensate for having all that
money well and you have the time and the
resour ources and you should have the a
lot of people like the regular people
don't have you know what I mean a lot of
people don't have time to spend days in
the gym a lot of people don't have time
to hire personal trainers or
nutritionists or anything like that most
people don't have time to do that [__] a
rich dude does yeah you do so honestly
there's kind of no excuse yeah and if
you want to spend all this money and F
basically look man the AR the archetype
the the perfect Rich dude is basically
Bruce Wayne the way he's way he's
presented in the [__] Dark Knight
series you I mean he's in
training you know he looks good he's got
all that money he's not to do all that
stuff he can just lay around and do
nothing yeah he could lay around do
nothing and get all these women no he's
[__] doing [__] and his standards for
himself are higher are high and he's not
imposing on these women he's rich but
they but they'd be want to be with him
even if he wasn't Rich right and I think
that's a good aspir much better way to
do it right I think that's a good
aspiration it's like even if you don't
have a [__] ton of money at least be
somebody that people want to be around M
that's all mhm you know have some
[__] self resect just make an effort
a lot of Rich dudes don't have any
self-respect well the thing is that a
lot of dudes expect women to look like
this that and the other thing which
takes a lot of money and effort but it's
like they're not willing to not going to
do nothing do that themselves which is
yeah I'm rich and Powerful I don't have
to be good-looking yeah okay so you're
just going to impose I don't have to go
get my hair done and my nails done and
get shaved and plucked and all this
other kind of stuff oh but women have to
do that right right like you have to go
get all this [__] done Sur it's misogyny
it well it is they expect women to look
a certain way which like I said that's
not free like most women don't look like
that naturally sorry they but they won't
put the same stands on right but they
won't put the same right and then this
dude this dude is that's why we get mad
this dude is a
billionaire uh [__] he he's got
everything life could give and he
doesn't want Health he doesn't want
[__] Charisma that's what I mean he
do want he has the money and the time
yeah have all that at least man go to
the spa yeah get become the full life
suction get a facial the thing get a
good haircut if I had that kind of money
I'd be working to
compensate because it to me I would see
that kind of money and power as a
weakness I'd [__] get real insecure
I'd be like man these women don't like
me they just like this money yeah I you
know what I mean so I'd be like well I'm
going have to do something about that
you know I have to be you have to make
sure you have to make sure that you're
check that they would like you either
way either way so you going to go on
training and [__] you know more
people should think like that I think
lot well you see me me growing up in
Brazil going to the scholar gr water to
S Pao run all those Rich Brazilian kids
and [__] like that they were [__]
Rich they don't think that way no I know
a lot of people don't a lot of rich
people no they're [__] losers their
dads were like [__] super rich and
powerful and [__] but they had like I
said whole harms of hookers and [__]
girlfriends and then a wife they just
saw women as disposable [__] right like
why the [__] they makeing after yeah
they like I'm GNA get fat I'll [__] her
I'll just pay her
yeah it's like well yeah it's like I
don't really give a [__] it's like oh my
wife leaves me I don't I don't care I'll
just I'll just pay for one they have to
they have to [__] me cuz I paid her
exactly they can't complain exactly so
you end up in a very hollow life
meaningless life because you don't have
any real friends right cuz every that
comes there is like oh Jesus Christ yeah
and you don't have any real girlfriends
your girlfriend's a [__] employee
right she's on the [__] payroll all
right yeah she wouldn't be with you
otherwi no way but yeah yeah like I said
they'll hang out with you if you got a
lot of money yeah if they're you know
yeah so cuz you're paying them so go
look at Jeff bezo Google Jeff bezos's
[__] HRT or [__] testosterone or
something and those pictures will come
up at him up on that yacht all right and
he's in his 50s and he looks [__]
great for
50s um he probably looks better now than
he did when those photos are taken and
his girlfriends are with is with him and
she's [__] hot and they don't look
out of place with each other yeah he
looks like a [__] [__] Playboy
billionaire like he took a [__] he
felt the same way I did I guarantee you
probably he's like they just like me for
the money [__] that I'm gonna go to the
gym I'm [__] get [__] shredded you
know what I mean so so I look like I
deserve this [__] I respect that I
respect that because at least you're
making an effort like I said because you
expect other people to make an effort so
you should he went Bruce he went Bruce
Wayne on the [__] which that's
what I would
do I'd have a whole [__] arsenal of
toys and [__]
I'd be [__] working out that's what I
mean like [__] I'd be on gear if I was a
billionaire holy crap it's like I would
have all kind of stuff done yeah if you
[__] watch The Animated Batman series
the newer ones man [__] Batman was on
gear he was he was on [__] special
steroids he Blended himself he was such
a genius because how could a dude
[__] 55 be that [__] jacked if you
look at the cartoons there's upper
body's [__] five times size of mine
talk about some Vaper that dude must
have weighed [__] 200 50 300 [__]
pounds of pure
muscle it's not natural for a dude's
[__] 50 [__] I don't remember what
the name of that cartoon that I saw was
it was old Batman he had a damn bat tank
and everything it was a good telling you
superhero [__] makes a lot more sense
when it's
animated well yeah I agree with that
yeah that Christopher Nolan I
Christopher Nolan right did the [__]
Dark Knight Series yeah that's about the
best that's the best superhero series
actually you can't for Live Action you
can't get any better than that Tom was
watching yeah this was um the villagers
react yeah guys from [__] Indian with
Baboo yeah Baboo his grandpa like that
super old dude super old [__] Indian
and they watched the Christopher Nolan
Batman series all three of them and they
thought those were the best movies ever
made in the history of and I think they
even compared Christopher Nolan to God
did they yeah they said they said
chrisel Nolan was an incarnation of God
yeah that's how much they love that's
how much they love yeah yeah they love
they love that [__] and they and they
they liked the stories they knew the
whole thing although here's the funny
thing in that that that last one they
just saying that girl that Thief girl
they didn't know that that was Catwoman
that Catwoman right they didn't know
that they just said that Thief girl
right they didn't know that that was a
super villain okay another one that was
funny that they didn't because they
didn't have the cultural reference uh
there was another one that they didn't
know who that was oh they didn't know
that that cop that was helping Batman
was Robin okay yeah they didn't know who
that was well like I said they're not as
um immersed in the L as we are over here
so that's like not yeah you know that's
not that weird they watched The Joker
too they loved that and there's a scene
in Joker where Joker kills some people
coming out of a theater and and and and
lets the boy live she they didn't
realize that that was Batman that that
was Batman they didn't realize that cuz
like I said they're not like yeah like
obviously in the west everybody be like
oh you know what I mean like everybody
would immediately know what that was but
you know they don't have the cultural
context so that's not like not that's
not the big of deal and they liked Joker
in both movies like Dark Knight 2 and
they liked the The Joker solo Series
right but they didn't really seem to
understand that they didn't quite F fit
together they didn't realize there's
reboots and Alternate universes of it
you know I mean you know that's kind of
a they were trying to figure out where
and history that was supposed to be
right in within the within the relative
of dark yeah because in the in the
context it doesn't really make sense
because obviously in the Joker movie
yeah you know Jo Joker is like
middle-aged when Bruce Wayne is a child
yeah and like in the other ones they're
kind of the same age same age right so
it's just kind of like you know
everyone's just we're not worrying about
it we're just kind of like making them
the same universe but yeah but the
Christopher Nolan movies I think are the
best
liveaction superhero movies in modern
times retro live action I'm gonna have
to give it to [__] Superman one and
two and
four yeah yeah [__] with Christopher
re even the one with nuclear man though
I [__] love nuclear man the Canon
film one yeah that's that's when
Superman goes straight [__] it straight
[__] it okay and and and and here's the
thing man [__] Chris Reeves had a lot
to do with uh nuclear man didn't he get
a production credit yeah he was
partially produced it and he wrote A lot
of it and he does a lot of idea he does
a lot of good work in that actually the
good acting it it the special effects
weren't up to Snuff uh no the opening
credits is really what brought it down
the opening credits were [__]
terrible they should have o the opening
scene should have somehow gotten around
highquality credits I would have just WR
written it a different way so you didn't
notice right because they tried to
replicate those credit those opening
credits and it just no yeah like if you
can't make it as good as it was
initially then just do something else
totally do if you try to like replicate
it everyone's going to notice that it's
not as good but it had a lot of it had a
lot of you know [__] uh Lex Luther
was back it was the same cast a lot of
the [__] [__] was back and it was uh
good I thought it was better than a
three
unfortunately because uh Richard PRI was
in it yeah I'd have to watch he was the
best part yeah Richard prior was
actually the best part of [__]
Superman he was yeah I agree and I feel
bad for prior because prior loved
[__]
Superman uh growing up as a kid in a
brothel he [__] looked up to Superman
he thought Superman was just a [__] a
dude who would come and save him um and
he loved Christopher Reeves Superman one
and two and when he got three he was
just [__] dumbfounded and he had him
change the script because his character
is supposed to like try to kill Superman
he's like no no no no no I'm not gonna
be in this movie if I'm kill super no
way he's like no that's not that's not
going to work for me way yeah and uh he
did a good job he was like the best
thing about that number three he was
very endearing in that movie I found I
mean he was very endearing in general
but I found him very endearing really
wanted that project to [__] work but
the director the direction was just
improper for that movie and they just
the direction was wrong it should should
have gone down that way I feel like they
couldn't really settle on a tone comedic
and yeah which was what was kind of
brought it down I do I I like that movie
um overall but yeah it's a little uh
skito yeah little
SK shouldn't have quite have been that
story yeah um there was there was other
stuff they could have done to make that
a good story and had still had Richard
PRI in it but that director was right
for that project Superman 4 was good
because it was just straight up a
lowbudget movie that was done pretty
well it had a lot of fun in it
um it was crazy the whole nuclear man
aspect I think was mised was super that
was a little misguided yeah that's
that's a good way to put it and what
what was fun on the nose it's a little
on the nose what was funny about that
one is that they oh Christopher reev was
responsible for that [__] do you know
that yeah I the nucle so if you want to
blame anybody [__] blame Reeves I
mean the problem is it was just so
Earnest yeah and like I said I get it
his heart was in the right place but you
could have at least like put a couple
more layers of metaphor on it so it
wasn't quite so on the nose it was very
much a kids movie because it's very
cringy it was very much a kids movie
even though it had good Superman action
in it Superman acting was good in it Lex
Luther [__] what's his name the guy
play Lex Luther he [__] Nails it Jean
Hackman yeah Jean Hackman [__] he
doesn't phone it in he's [__] chewing
up the whole [__] scenery all right
um all of it yeah it was the thing is is
that Chris Reeves almost had it there
almost instead of the nuclear man thing
the way they made him they made him out
of some of Superman's hair if I remember
correctly yeah like the DNA what they
should have done is made a [__] clone
of Superman and Chris Reed played them
both yeah that's what it should have
been and then the Clone would have been
slightly imperfect and was more loyal to
[__] Lex Luther that's how they that
would have been much Co that would have
made a lot more
sense and then
somehow Superman destroys the Clone but
with the help of the Clone that's how I
would do it because a clone or the
Superman deep down would still be good
yeah cuz he's a clone of Superman right
and what would happen was is he would
that the clone of Superman there'd be
like I I would put in so this is me
coming up with [__] scripts right
Hollywood should [__] hire me all
right look I mean take a class or
something you'd probably be really good
at it I would I'm little I can write
this [__] for you I'm a little old for
that [__] now but no you're not what I
would have done is had a [__] scene
where the clone of Superman self-
actualizes and it's like wait a minute
hold on this isn't right I'm this is
[__] up I'm a clone of Superman but
I'm still Superman man and what I should
do in this situation is not only betray
Lex Luther but destroy myself yeah I'm
going to do and throws himself into the
Sun or some [__] like that after he sa
so the bad guy Superman actually saves
the planet I like that idea that's how I
would do it and really the good guy
Superman basically kind of influences
him and talks him into doing that right
all right because there's a bunch of
problems in Superman 3 Superman decides
on his own because he's got [__] nuts
of Steel that he's going to make nuclear
weapons [__] illegal and get rid of
them all that's a wrong
answer even his training when he's
flying in the [__] spaceship from
[__] Krypton and [__] says you cannot
interfere with human history they they
gave him all kinds of rules it would
have been like a prime directive all
right well he whiffed that didn't he he
whiffed that you [__] not only did he
[__] up time all right he also [__] up
human history and [__] by about trying
to get rid of the nuclear weapons cuz
what would have really happened in those
days of the Cold War if you knew the
United States and the Soviet Union had
you got rid of those nuclear weapons
they would have immediately started
fighting World War III with each other
yeah wow it' have been better than World
War II so millions of people would have
died the nuclear weapons is what CAU
kept the peace that's what kept Him from
[__] attacking each other because
both sides were pretty were responsible
the Soviet guys were professional we
were professional became a game they
weren't going to launch on each other
but either side really didn't want to
die you got rid of nuclear weapons
they'd [__] go Toe to Toe there
wouldn't be any proxy wars and a real
Superman would have known that he would
have come up with another
solution
um like uh [__] some kind of peace
treaty you know what I mean that would
have [__] made sure that it didn't
happen it would have been something like
that it would have been Lex Luther would
have used the [__] Superman the the
Clone Superman to do something to cause
the [__] right nuclear war to happen
that's how it should should have been
and Superman stops it with the help of
the Clone Superman that's how that movie
should have been that would have been a
good idea that would have been a lot
better like I said you're just making if
you're just making a villain and they're
like okay well who is the villain oh
well he represents all the nuclear
powers of the world it's like let's call
him nuclear man that sounds like a like
a
nine-year-old's yeah first draft right
is all I'm saying I no no hate I'm just
saying that's what it sounds like I
would have had it so the clone of
Superman was damn near indistinguishable
from the real Superman and most people
thought that the Clone was the real one
nobody knew which one so see look at all
of the
conf right there would have been a bunch
of [__] that great confusion and only
the audience could would have known who
the real who the they could have had
like a little bit of a tell so the
audience could tell the difference so
the audience could tell the difference
but the people couldn't like he was
slightly dingy looking or something or
something something like that or he was
slightly like maybe his hair was wrong
or something or [__] man even they could
have it where like in Universe like no
one would be able to tell but like the
audience would be able to tell CU it was
a slightly different theme music right
so it's like so you always knew like
which one was the bad one you know what
I mean right so then that would
introduce like a lot more suspense
because you'd be like oh [__] everybody
thinks this is like the real one but
it's not right and you see I would have
had it so the Clone Superman really
wasn't all that bad it's just that he
was under the influence of [__] Lex
Luther and Lex was lying to his ass
about something and tricking him into in
this nuclear world to happen yeah cuz he
wasn't like deep down he wasn't a bad no
cuz he was a clone of Superman right
still be a good been a good guy so but
but Lex Luther would have been tricking
him right into doing something to cause
this nuclear war again more conflict
which would have been yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then [__] he's told [__]
Lex has told the Clone Superman that the
other Superman is a clone right so
there's a lot of confusion and it's got
to be sorted out inside the Fortress of
Solitude that's where it's all sorted
out you need to write that movie going
to write that [__] right [__] now you
go to this Fortress of Solitude and
[__] Jerell shows up his [__] AI
[__] thing and [__] whatever and
he's like we have a crystal for that and
then he comes out yeah and then [__] jel
comes out and goes you are in in many
ways both my sons all the kind of weird
[__] like that and Jerel gets get gets
the Clone Superman to destroy
himself for the benefit of the universe
like hey you you need to like jump off
the bridge or something right or he
leaves and becomes an extra Superman
just in case our Superman gets destroyed
you he goes back to another he flies to
another planet some [__] like that got
an extra Superman bonus
Superman yeah just in case well it's
always good to have one on backup it's
backup Superman although I think it
makes more sense if the I think it makes
more sense that the Clone Superman
destroys himself well it would be a lot
more dramatic more dramatic and it's
more heroic standpoint yeah he destroys
himself he just takes off everybody like
okay he tries to save the Earth somehow
and in in in the course of it he [__]
destroys himself yeah cuz that's always
like cuz everybody everybody loves that
when that happens self sacrifice at the
end of a movie and that way you get to
see the Superman was really down with
that [__] that he would die yeah to
protect Earth actual Superman didn't
have to die but just CL super yeah
exactly like yeah I'll do that yeah
that's how I would do it that way both
of going to walk into the volcano one
was a villain for a while and then they
both became kind of Heroes and you get
to see your hero die but but the but
yours but not the real one not the real
one just the bonus one right the spare
Superman the spare
Superman Superman 2 Electric Boogaloo
yeah what's up Dave Dave is here uh Dave
he says totally reboot the nuclear Man
movie he's like oh and hey you two hey
you going to mannequins tonight I
imagine you probably are we're not
because we're broke ass yeah we're kind
of broke so we're not going and we got
to save money uh for Halloween I know
Halloween is only in 11 days so yeah
that's coming
up plus we spent money at the bar yeah
at the Oasis which I wasn't even
planning to go really but he just came
out and said hey Melissa and her
boyfriend are going to Daytona and
they're stopping at the Oasis and I was
like oh he's like I'm going to ride down
I was like well I'll drive down in my
car and because I hadn't seen her a long
time either so you know thank you thank
you so I went down there too a thank you
very much Bryce love the show I usually
don't get to listen to sidetracks
because of work and study by the way
have you guys tried what is that Prov
provigil am I pronouncing that right
because of it I got an essay done in one
night oh I like that oh don't temp no I
never tried that no know what that
isct says Superman 2 The Legend of
Curly's
gold Superman 2 what the legend of
Curly's gold that was um that was the uh
oh [__] man what that movie with [__]
Billy Crystal in it and God damn it it
just totally went out of my head what
movie that was what but that was what
the sequel was called The Legend of
Curly's gold he'll tell me in a second
Victor uh my other gay he he's in there
saying that his favorite Superman was
[__] breitburn that was a good one I
really I liked breit burn a lot more
than I thought I would I wanted to get
breitburn on [__] Blu-ray but I
forgot about City lickers that's what
thank you very much I could not remember
the name of that movie to save my
[__] life I wanted to get that one on
blue W but I forgot about I forgot to
get it and I kind of the end of
breitburn kind of teased another movie
like but they wanted to make like a
whole like un whole universe but they
they pushed out on it maybe that one
didn't do well enough I liked that movie
though I kind of feel like I don't know
it kind of came and went like we
reviewed it when it was in the theater
and I remembered liking that like much
more than I thought that I was going
to Camp guy said who played Lex Luther's
female assistant she was pretty hot yeah
M Mrs uh what was Mrs is uh Tess Boer
right Tess Boer yeah that was what he
used to call her right I think it was
test Boer yeah what the [__] was her I I
can see her face what is her [__]
name I know that actress's
name but I can't again I can't she was
just a um Camp gu said Valerie perin
baby she was just a super cougar from
the
80s super cougar from the8 Super cougar
from the 80s well she's about 40 I think
when you I think it was the same kind of
vibe as like um Annie pots from
Ghostbusters yeah I was
watching a modern although Annie pots
from pretty and pink who was like a punk
rocker I was I was I was all about that
I was watching a modern reaction video
some uh goth chick she's in her 20s
watched the that movie she liked it she
go the only thing I couldn't stand about
that is when that woman kissed Superman
when he was had the when he was in the
water freaking without his permission
that was that was horrible that should
have never been in the movie I was just
[__] laughing as these [__] gen Z
they don't they don't understand [__]
men don't have to worry about that kind
of [__] she just did that because she
couldn't get a good guy and she wanted
to have the experience to kiss the
Superman that cute [__] that's
all that was well like I said and she's
she freed him it was not like raping him
or something you know yeah well the
thing is it's like I get it but you have
to understand too that it's like it's
not the same as it would be the other
way around no it it's not the same if a
dude did that to a woman but they but
that is absolutely not the same yeah
that's kind of taking advantage of the
woman but the thing is is that a woman
is a beautiful a beautiful woman is not
taking advantage of a man if he kisses
if she kisses him he takes that [__] as
a [__] as as a as a compliment most
of the time he was like like I said I'm
not a big advocate of like well not if
he's like unconscious or something like
that cuz that's [__] up whoever you do
it to but it's just kind of like if he's
just kind of standing there and like I
said it's not the same the other way
around it's just not well I told already
told J my [__] story I
[__] up in Boston partying and one of
them [__] damn College [__] frat
houses and they had all the [__]
people in there and I passed out on a
damn [__] recliner [__] as drunk
as I was when I woke up some chick was
making out with me yeah and I was like
what who are you and she's [__]
trying to pull me she's like come on
come on I say yeah yeah hold on hold on
hold on I was going to go with her and I
just [__] stumbled [__] passed out so
I couldn't go anywhere I was so [__]
up yeah and then I woke up and everybody
was gone it was morning time I like I
got to get out of here
looking went back to the tea and went
home I didn't know where I was yeah like
I said it's that's not the same as doing
that not the same as the other way
around like I've fallen asleep drunk at
a few parties a few times yeah and if I
had woken up and some dude was like on
top of me making out with me I would
absolutely not have reacted the way he
reacted women fck women have to Pro have
to like protect their [__] sanctity
and their dignity that's [__] men
have to know that you got a woman who's
drunk and she's [__] passed out you
got to you you should protect her not
take advantage of her well well honestly
even if you're a woman and a dude is
passed out you shouldn't take advantage
of them either I mean it's like they
probably wouldn't be upset but I'm not
going to take that chance man I wouldn't
want to like why do you want to make out
with a dude that's asleep anyway well
she was trying to get me awake I guess
but it's just like I don't know that
wouldn't occur to
me she was [__] up too well yeah maybe
but it's like I see some dude that I had
a crush on if he was like sleeping I
would not it would not occur to me in a
million years oh I'm going to go like
jump on that dick while he's sleeping I
would never do that well you never went
to college yeah it that was [__] girl
what you talking about which college you
go to Daytona State oh okay I thought
okay I didn't see you don't know [__]
about me I know you got I know you got a
degree but I didn't I thought that was
just yeah and it's just kind of like
well I didn't like living a dorm or
anything like that but it's just kind of
like right I used to dorm people well
yeah but I'm just saying even in that
sense like yeah I used to go to parties
and [__] like that but it's just kind of
like I don't know that would just never
I just wouldn't do that to somebody it
just wouldn't occur to me girls do that
[__] all the time I know they do but
they get away with it because I'm not
that type of with it they can estimate
what dudes available and [__] you know
what I mean dudes are not real uh choosy
as long as you're a cute girl and he's
not and and and he's single he he's
gonna he's gonna say yeah you know he's
not gonna [__] he's gonna go okay
yeah even if she's slightly below your
standards you'd probably say okay you
I'm gonna do this your chick a favor you
know she's kind of ugly but I'm GNA do
it anyway because you don't have a
girlfriend you know what I mean you're
just okay we'll do this well a lot of
dudes will have do it even if they do
have a girlfriend yeah a lot of them
will yeah but uh you know it's not the
same guys are easy to satisfy women are
choosy they they like to date up you
know certain guys well like I said we
have to be we have a lot more to lose
than yall do yeah right the guy didn't
have anything to lose he's just be
single he's just like all right okay
this is fun yeah I mean like you're not
going to get raped or murdered anything
girl can't hurt you or pregnant or
anything like that yeah girl can't hurt
you I mean you might get an STD which is
sucky but just a [__] year ago me and
Jen went down to [__]
mannequins and I was dressed as
Bane yeah this was last Halloween last
Halloween I had the the the comic book
Bane the comic book Bane so like the El
Santo looking yeah he look like a
[__] Mexican Luchador and I was
Medusa yeah I had a kickass costume last
[__] and I had his [__] combat boots
and black [__] pants and [__]
wrestling kind of wrestling shirt outfit
went through there and [__] I was
getting groped I was getting groped I
walked by a bunch of girls with [__]
hand came out and just grabbed my
[__] Teddy and [__]
I turn around like what the [__] is that
and they start giggling and [__]
dudes could never do that to a woman you
better not no you do that to me and I'll
[__] punch you in the mouth couldn't
do that to a woman and get away with it
or I'll I do or I'll kick you in the
tank Jim was right next to me when I I
was right there we were walking out to
the back [__] it wasn't even he
wasn't even by himself walking right
walking the back trying to call me over
there with she was probably super wasted
I imagine everybody was it was Halloween
it was crowed everybody was super wasted
yeah then later on over there getting a
drink and
some she probably about 21 you know
[__] smoking hot mini skirt she was
with this dumpy old dude who maybe paid
for her company I don't [__]
know she was up on that [__] bar and
[__] you know giving everybody a [__]
upskirt and she jumped down like that
[__] turned around and saw me and
just went and started heading towards me
and he saw her heading towards me he
pulled her
back yeah that I did not see I must have
been in no you were in the back you were
out on the patio I was out on the patio
I went out there to go get us both a
drake she [__] went right I was like
five feet she went right towards and he
[__] grabbed
her I think I think he was a client
though could have been well she was
[__] in heels maybe six feet he was
maybe
52 and [__] like a round ball I mean
he no he had to been paying yeah you
would think he was some kind of
Foreigner had a lot of money but he was
maybe 25 we're not talking about an old
guy young
guy h i wonder maybe like a young middle
easterner or something somebody who had
a lot of money yeah both of us get
groped when we go there she gets groped
that's how I got fight yeah yeah I get
grab her ass and I'm
next that's why I don't really like
going there
yeah like I said that's the same reason
like see that's kind of the difference
between dudes and women it's like Tom is
like oh I like to go to that place it's
like I kind of like it but in a way I
don't and honestly like last time we
were at momento which is at Barbarella
and we were talking to people about
mannequins there and a lot of people
like the goth people will not go they're
like I don't feel safe there and it's
like and I understand that because it's
like they let too many douchebags in
they are trying to make it better they
like started a cover charge and they're
you know the the DJ is pretty um you
know he'll call people out if people are
being like [__] like the dance Flor
like hey get off the [__] Dance Floor
get out of here or whatever but um so
they are trying to like make it better
but it's still I still don't feel like
super safe there and it's like whenever
Tom goes to the bathroom or I have to go
somewhere like by myself in the place
like I just I'm always like on edge and
I don't really like that like at
Barbarella um you can go there like you
could go there with just tape over your
nipples and your cooch and no one would
bad an eye yeah you could dance all
night no one would touch you no one
would look at you funny no one would do
anything no everybody would just like
hey what's up and okay I'm going to go
back to dancing you just do your thing
and it's like and it's so freeing you
know what I mean you go to mannequins
you have to like watch your back every
[__] second yeah cuz it's like is
this dude going to grope me is this dude
going to is this dude going to like yeah
you know do something in the parking lot
is he going to like wait for me or
something like that like's funny is that
they know what's funny is that they know
I'm there yeah and I don't know if they
understand the body count how many dudes
are [__] up there but well and another
thing even Security's kind of [__]
scared to tell me anything you know what
I mean but [__] uh well I'm I'm a
friend of the owners too but you can't
do what I do we've the owner for a long
long time so if we go to him and say hey
these people are being Ked out then
they'll get rid of them although we had
this happen was it last week or the week
before yeah I guess it was the week
before because I think we went to
momento last week but the week before
there were these like really douchy
dudes like on the [__] dance FL and
they were just being so irritating they
got kicked out once well and then yeah
and then the DJ kept saying it's like
hey stop being douchebags out there it's
like you're going to get kicked out or
whatever and then they were like what us
so we're not being douche and everyone's
like um they're talking about you so you
know like straighten up and so they
wouldn't and then finally they got
kicked out why are we being kicked out
oh oh I can't imagine so they got kicked
out but then like an hour later they
were back in there yeah they came back
in there like that's I was like well
look all normies look the same to me not
to be racist but all normies like kind
of look the same to me so they came back
in and later on we're we're over there
me and Tom and I think we were talking
to Dave actually and we were like in the
corner and I was like is that those same
[__] again I was like normies
look the same to me but I'm pretty sure
that's the same dudes well they all have
the same stupid shorts they all the same
stupid shoes they're dude Bros they all
have the same stupid backwards baseball
caps I'm like they all look the same to
me so it's like I don't know they all
look like just generic White dudes so
I'm just kind of like is that them I was
like that looks like them and Tom's like
look he's like that's not them I'm like
I'm pretty sure that's them and we're
looking at him he's like oh wait I think
that is them and I was like what the
[__] are they doing back did they pay
again yeah did they pay again just
because they were bad that they got
kicked out what's funny is that their
girls are just as bad they are I I will
admit that they're just guilty they all
look the same to me too I can't tell one
from the other to be honest they all
look like Karens yeah they're just
guilty of different [__] what they do is
they get the middle dance Flo and get a
circle and put their purses all in the
center of the circle and just bounce up
and down it's not even [__] dancing
they're not aggressive it's just passive
aggressive yeah they're just taking up
room room and that could be made up by
people that were actually dancing I'm
like if you're just going to do that go
stand off on the edge and then they go
[Music]
wooo which I hate that oh my God [__]
dance I hate that yeah because it's just
so like I said I hate all of that like
super attention seeking Behavior then
they pull the phone out and they take it
comes across as like so insecure they're
taking selfies while they're dancing
they're not really dancing they're just
jumping up and down they're just
bouncing up and
down because you can like they're not
even like enjoying themselves really
they just want other people on their
social media to be like look we're out
and we're doing stuff we're so cool and
I'm just like [__] knock it off if
you really want to have a good time just
have a good time don't take pictures of
yourself pretending like you're having a
I chased five of them off of [__] Dan
Jesus Christ remember I chased I hate
that crap I remember when I chased him
off a dance floor I know well they were
just standing there standing there
jumping up and down and one of them was
acting a fool and kept bouncing kept
knocking into me remember that well she
kept knocking into everybody cuz she was
[__] I don't know what the fck and
she was hopping around like a bunny
rabbit literally oh my God you see
somebody doing the bunny I was going
slug her I told Tom I'm like I'm GNA
slug this [__] in a minute so impact
number five I was like [__] it so I just
grabbed her around the waist and just
started grinding up on her like I was
just [__] a porn star and [__] and
and then [__] when the other ones
tried to stop me did the same thing I'm
just [__] just trying to get my nuts
up in them and everything and then they
realized that this isn't going to stop
all right [__] I'm there to dance and
if you're near me you're going to dirty
dance well they all just [__]
eventually just
went and stampeded off the [__] Dance
Floor remember that and then all the
Goths took over and filled this vacuum
that they left well they're always kind
of happy there's it's like hilarious
because when they see me drive them out
they all get happy well when when we
were at mannequins a couple weeks ago
cuz like I said everyone was like
irritated by these cuz it wasn't just a
just wasn't just one dude it was like
five or six dudes and they were like in
this big crowd and they were just like
being really obnoxious and they were
just kind of like taking up I mean the
dance FL isn't big so like they were
kind of taking up a lot of room and
people were just getting really annoyed
with them and but you know we're gos
we're kind of too polite to say anything
so we're just kind of like whatever I'm
just going to go dance over here because
you don't want to like start a big
[__] fight or anything like that but
it's just kind of like after a while
you're just kind of like Jesus Christ is
somebody going to punch these
[__] and then like people will
start doing passive aggressive [__] like
just backing into them and it's like oh
sorry like with the elbow and everything
but like they weren't even getting that
message so after a while they were just
being really obnoxious and then after
that I was just kind of like I was like
you know what I'm just going to put my
foot out here and just wait for one of
them to fall over and then you know Tom
started yelling at them and I started
yelling I'm like you know what get the
[__] out it's like nobody wants you here
and it's like I don't know you're
[__] problem is and they're like what
do we do and it's like yeah well figure
it out well they don't have any club
culture right they understand At Last At
Last they got kicked out the second they
got kicked out all of the goth people
flooded the dance floor and the vibe
immediately got awesome yeah like
everyone was just like woo we can like
[__] dance the way we want to dance
and like no one is being obnoxious no
one is being a pain in the ass it's just
like so it just shows how just a couple
of people like that can just ruin the
night for everybody but they don't
realize that they're doing that
now Victor man uh last time we were at
uh uh [__] barbarell there was one up
there man had your name all over him all
right they had a dude old bear man they
had a bear up there a hairy ass bear I
forgot you know I'm talk about right
hairy ass bear I forgot about that guy
okay he he looked like he' been lifting
some he had a high percentage of body
fat but he was like a [__] bear he
had [__] shoulders and chest and arms
and all that kind of [__] he was wearing
nothing but a G string and a whole bunch
of Le Le straps I think he had some like
leather Wings on too Le Wings was it a
black bunny tail I think so I think it
was a b like a puffy he had tails and
wings and horns that's what I'm talking
about Barbarella you can just come in
wearing leather straps yeah and
everyone's just like whatev yeah that no
one no one looked at him funny nothing
no that dude that dude that dude was he
danced all night and everybody's like
yeah and that dude was aside from his
junk being covered was straight up nude
basically he naked he naked and [__]
the girl the girls all cool with it
they're like yeah okay he's he look good
he's he's dressed right and he's
behaving right so it's not like you
could yeah he didn't do anything about
he was just he was having a good time
yeah all the like whatever music and he
was into the older music too because
they played a lot of older music like
ear like earlier like Susan the banshe
yeah he's about 30 yeah and he was a
younger guy he was he was behind me lot
he was just he was all into it man and I
was just like okay he he he was behind
me Liv truth man he was behind me and he
goes man you look great you look great
man [__] He's dude yeah he was he was
a gy bro he was a gym
bro uh I don't know if he was gay though
I think he was maybe it's hard to say
it's [__] hard to say yeah I don't
really know like I said in the go scene
I don't really worry about it too much
because it's just kind of like everyone
everyone's so gender fluid that it's
like I'm not really woring it was about
50/50 probably could be could be not no
one really cares we didn't know we
didn't that's the first time we've seen
him well he came with he was definitely
definitely a scer we talked to um
Demitri our friend who's the DJ at
momento and he said oh we got a bunch of
people that normally go to mannequins on
Friday night cuz for a while I don't
know if they still do it but for a while
they were having the quote unquote baby
bat Invasion which was all the little
baby Goths which is like which is crazy
but it's like kids in their 20s who are
into like old school goth music yeah
it's funny they know more [__] than we
know sometimes they do like I said like
our friend Nick who was like [__] who
what is he 21 22 yeah he can name B I've
never heard of he's into like [__]
Christian death and joy he loves that
[__] he'll know that's how we met him at
first cuz we saw him and I was like oh
my God he looks like a baby but he
looked like an old death rocker like he
had like a [__] Christian death shirt
on he had big [__] hair and [__] and
I was just like you love you'd love him
Victor you'd love him Victor he's he
he's tall and thin and uh cute looking
and uh he's awesome I like yeah he's
straight but uh you'd like him and we
saw him at mannequins a couple weeks ago
and he was trash he wasn't even make any
sense I'm like what no what he's he was
wasted when he got there and then like
as the night went on I was just like I
have no idea what you're talking about
[__] pinching his cheeks and I'm what
are you saying
Sunny it was so funny I know what the
[__] he was saying he's adorable he
looks like uh he kind of looks like
a kind of looks like a young uh Johnny
roton he does a bit like a young a
little bit without the [__] up eyes
one his hair black his hair yeah his
hair is black he looks like an old
school like I said he's like an old
school if you time traveled back to the
early 80s and went to like some death
Rock Club like you went to slimelight or
something like that I don't even know if
that was around in the early 80s but if
you went to that or the back cave or
something he looks like somebody from
there yeah but it's now and he's young
yeah and like I said that's how he's
like some kid we grew up with yeah and
that's how we met him because we saw him
at mannequin and like I said he was full
on death I was like oh my God I was like
he looks like some kid from like 1982
that I would have known back Aaliyah was
his girlfriend who was about a they're
not together anymore they're not
together anymore but he she was like two
years younger she was just legal enough
to get in she couldn't drink though
they're separated now though um she
ended up coming down with a bad drug
problem they're trying to get her some
help but anyway uh he uh he was he's a
good kid they're both good they're both
good kids they just they they come from
rough backgrounds but I'll tell you they
both do they both come from families
that had histories yeah of this problem
um but
uh uh he's smart he's real smart yeah
and he works you know got a job so he he
can take care of himself well doesn't he
work like in a in a print shop or he's
worked in print shops and restaurants
all kinds of stuff uh he he [__] gets
inebriated but he's legal you know he's
he's 21 can't judge he does other [__]
too but he's keeping
way I can't judge
yeah yeah I'm always giving him lectures
about doing junk I said do not [__]
do that [__] and he's like yeah yeah I
want because his dad that killed his dad
and he's always had this [__] kind of
secret desire to try it to see there is
like a to see what his dad went through
type of d i says dude do not [__] do
that [__] I was telling him all the dud
I told about rich who my friend was in
that who killed himself with that [__] I
don't know anybody who's ever [__]
with that came back out of that normal
and I'm somebody who can smoke Opium and
walk away from it I don't think opium is
I get it and I and it's probably worse
for people that grew up at in the time
that we grew up cuz there was a weird
kind of like Romanticism about
itally and especially if you were into
um you know the goth scene or like any
kind of underground art scene or
anything like that cuz a lot of people
were on that like back in the 70s and '
80s so there was almost some like kind
of a Romanticism about it and I kind of
like got into that
wasar but how be kind ofing to during
that era I was in
Boston and there were so many just cool
intelligent and beautiful goth fetish D
stripper girls who were dying from
heroin one of them was a girl new named
sin and she yeah a lot of people did it
was [__] up I mean people that didn't
grow up back then you don't understand
how many people died really young
because of that [__] yeah s that and
AIDS took out a lot of people back then
sin uh was a stripper down the combat
zone but she also was one of one of the
barbituates which is like a dance team
that that did shows with a a fetish
industrial band called Sleep chamber I
was friends with John ziz who was a
[__] vocalist sleep chamber he was
much older than me he's still alive
though he had a problem all right he was
friends with Rich who was my friend at
that time who was 50 back then but you
looked at him he look like he's 25 no he
look like he about 35 actually and he
died he killed himself with a pistol but
it was heroin related all right um sin
was [__] probably one of the best
looking goth chicks in the scene
and got a got hold of some good [__] and
killed her yeah like I said it happened
a lot I've showed videos on this show
here of her dancing on stage AG with him
and she was just this beautiful
dancer she was a dancer really she was a
trained dancer but she was stripping
that's where that's where their money
came from well yeah you you girl got to
pay bills right she had that she had a
[__] super good body dancers type
body she wore a black short bob at the
ears kind of like Susie had it was like
that
1920s 1930s German Cabaret looking yeah
when then she'd wear like rubber mini
skirts with [__] rubber [__] uh uh
[__] thigh highs and boots and rubber
[__] high uh uh [__] cocktail
gloves
and she looked great and she seemed
Invincible man knowing her she was great
she had that problem
though and one day she got a hold of
that [__] some good [__] and it
killed her man that's what I mean that
happened a lot yeah I was having a I
remember one time you know
[__] I think I already told this on
the story one time she came up [__]
lip locked me and put something in my
mouth and it was a watered up piece of
paper and I went to rich said what was
that she goes that was
coke and I was like oh oh okay so I put
it I put it in my back pocket forgot all
about
it she was that was one of her side gigs
is try to [__] sell Coke right so she
was trying to make a new
customer but she came over the [__]
house to my apartment a couple times and
she was trying to hook up but I was kind
of scared of her because of her drug
connections I didn't know how dangerous
this was you
know you know was she [__] involved
in a bunch of organized crime you know
what I mean is getting involved so I was
able to kind of get out of that and and
stay friends with
her
I hadn't seen her in about two weeks we
had this party and I said said what
happened to sin and they just looked at
me just she's dead I was like
what oh yeah she died two two three
weeks
ago I was like no what happened you know
she you she you know she overdose she
ODed and I was just I was happened a lot
I was just [__] beside myself and
then they went right back to [__]
snort and Coke and [__] like I said
big deal it sounds callous but it
happened a lot yeah I was like these
[__] are psychos man it's not
like we didn't care yeah it's just that
it happened so
much yeah which is [__] up yeah you
know you knew people that that that
happened to you knew people that you
know committed suicide like blew their
heads off and stuff like that like Yeah
It's upsetting but it's like it happened
a lot so yeah Rich
Campbell what you talking about blow his
head off was a friend of mine who was he
was in the same scene and he was friends
with John and he was in like I think he
was 52 or 53 at the time he killed
himself his girlfriend name was C at the
time she was this mixed goth chick um
from California uh she was [__] great
too but they were both on that [__] she
was only about 25 and he was about
52 they got into a fight they were high
and drunk cuz that [__] could
snort
coke shoot up and drink a fifth of
[__] scotch and still remain standing
I can't imagine all right he was 50
[__]
two looking at him now looking back at
him physically he looks like I look now
he was a like a thinner though he didn't
have a lot of muscle on him he was very
well preserved and he had he had hair
though black hair he got into a [__]
fight with his girlfriend over the
[__] volume of the [__] television
while they were watching [__]
Excalibur
and according to her he [__] R went
into the [__] walk-in closet and came
out in his [__] Army dress greens
[__] top he got out as a spec four
same rank as me and he goes I'm [__]
sick of this [__] you got no honor
[__] he mentioned he he said the only
people I know that are worth B well the
only [__] that understand me
basically said in this whole [__]
scene are are Tom and Eric and he was
talking about me and my other Army buddy
cuz he was Army too and he goes I'm sick
of the [__] I'm out of here and put the
[__] 30 Special revolver to his head
pulled the trigger right in front of her
blew his head off pop he hit the ground
in a moment of weakness yeah cuz that's
he would have done that normally I mean
he was probably so [__] up he wasn't
thinking about it he Fu he was [__] up
which is that's really sad he did that
[__] in a moment over the volume of the
television well like I said it wasn't
just over that no he was he was [__]
frustrated about a bunch of other [__]
but it built up that's what that's what
pushed him over the edge and I I showed
a picture of him when he was he gave me
a a picture of him on a Runway he was a
he had like a side gig doing fashion
modeling and [__] for the new wave scene
when he was kid you know I want say kid
you know 20s he gave me one of those
pictures I think I showed it proba is it
around here it's probably up there I
thought there was something up there
that you it was in a frame right it used
to be in a frame but I took it out of
the frame oh okay I thought if it was in
a frame then it's up there otherwise I
don't know where it
is cuz I thought you showed it
before it Victor says throw everything
Frank yeah I told you yeah I remember
Victor Victor says throw everything they
tell you about eating right and
exercising out the window I had a
75-year-old patient who could walk
around without assistance mentally 100%
with it and he was an IV drug user yeah
I mean that happens yeah that happens so
was he man and this is him this is him
probably 25 but that was rich he kind of
reminded me a lot of uh um Gary
Newman he looks a little bit a little
kind of like Gary Newman he's got a
little ray gun in his
hand ah the 80s yeah that was rich I
mean I rich rich [__] I think the re
reason why Rich [__] look so young it
is at 50 [__] two or 53 it's cuz he
slept most of the time I think a lot of
heroin he was like a vampire yeah well I
think that's why the thing we've said
about this like I said I've never done
heroin I've done um LSD I've done Coke
I've done uh you
know uh marijuana but that's about it
and I drink a lot but other than that
it's just like I'm I'm I never really
wanted to do heroin I'm like yeah no I
don't want to get involved in that yeah
but I feel like heroin either kills you
super
early if you survive it then you remain
remark well preserved into your old age
because look at people like Nick Cave or
Iggy Pop or somebody like that who are
still kicking around and they still are
thin and they still like look pretty
good like for as old as they are they
sleep a lot they don't eat much their
metabolism just crawling I kind of feel
like that I got I got a feeling that um
I got a feeling that uh Mick Jagger is a
[__] junkie too I just got to feel
that would not Shock me that would not
Shock Me got to feel those guys are
pretty much all junk like I said if you
don't die when you're young um I think
it might have some benefits but most of
the people that are on it are like die
when they're pretty young but those two
rich and Cay man every time I'd triy to
go Rouse them it was like waking
vampires up out of the crypt it [__]
he lived on Commonwealth a was [__]
nice he was a like a he was kind of like
the maintenance superintendent of a
[__] real expensive building on
Commonwealth a is old old building look
like a [__] government building or
something all made out of marble and
[__]
and part of his job they just gave him a
free apartment and all he had to do is
just go fix [__] like [__] pipes and
[__] know I've thought about doing that
yeah he had
that well there'd be all kinds of [__]
going on at the
club and [__] we didn't have cell
phones back then they were they were
existed but they were [__] super
expensive only rich people
had and like man where the [__] is rich
man I hadn't seen that dude in a [__]
week I said that [__] is [__] laid
up there with his [__] [__] [__]
zoned out on [__] junk man I'm going
to wake his ass up and I'm just on a
[__] [__] cay was cool she was all
right yeah don't call her a [__] that's
yeah yeah just I'm just saying you know
she kind of helped drag him down because
likeing he'd collect she wasn't the only
one there was a series these young
heroin girls that [__] went through
there and I think they perpetuated his
problems he would attract them and then
they would perpetuate
it
so I'd always have to Rouse them out of
[__] bed and [__] and and well not
really bed they didn't sleep in beds
they slept in couches and on Floors they
never made it to the [__] bed right
You' see them up in the slay let me in
and [__] we like and we like we got
man there's a [__] event going on
she's like yeah yeah that sounds good
and then you know [__] he'd be zoned
out she you wake up wake up rich and
he's like come on get your wear this ass
out bed he's
like like that and [__] they wake up
they
man just fcking relive In Those Old
Times fuing slay was always trying to
pull us into threesom and [__] she was
[__] kiky [__] I think she had a
porn background I'm not sure but she
seemed like it I'm going to tell you
though it's like not you know no shade
against um people that do drugs if you
want to do drugs that's up to you but
I'm just saying that um I've never been
a big fan of like look if we're going to
go do something like hey we're going to
go to this concert or whatever if I show
up at your [__] house and you are
sleeping and I have to wake you up and
you have to like get dressed and stuff
like I'm just going by myself yeah
that's not the way it was back then you
know that's not the way it was uh when
you're young because I don't have the
patience for that [__] I just really
don't when you're young and back in
those when we're going somewhere we're
going somewhere at the time we said
we're going to go somewhere I'm not
coming there and like waiting three
hours for your dumbass to wake up and
get ready I'm sorry that's not how it
was though because no I know and I and I
knew a lot of people like that because
look I'm a very um you know I I'm not
going to say I'm a super put together
person but I was just like look if we
plan something and we're going to do
something a particular time I'm planning
on doing something at that particular
time I'm going to be ready and you
better be [__] ready or I'm going
with out you that's all I'm saying you
see what was happening at this time you
know there wasn't cell phones and I was
in Boston and Boston has a te system a
train system Subways yeah yeah and all
you had to do is just buy the the tea
pass it was like [__] 15 or 20 bucks
a month and you could go anywhere in the
city and it was quick and pretty easy so
it was actually easier to just jump on a
te and go to somebody's house to check
on him and you know he wouldn't he
wasn't showing up to the club re you
know regularly I'm like well tonight's
[__] going to be a good night man
it's [__] Wednesday it's [__] goth
night that [__] hasn't been there in
[__] two weeks I'm gonna go get his
ass so you go down there early yeah at
like 7 CU you know you got to give them
time to [__] get ready and [__] you
know and so I'd go down there early and
start and they'd be asleep at [__] 7
in the evening you know CU they're
[__] knocked out you know and once
you got can't I can't live that way once
once he got moving he was all right they
were both you
know and cay was fun man she was fun to
[__] be around
because I'm like [__] 25 at this time
selay was probably about the same age 24
25 and [__] Rich was like 50s
something but he looked like he was in
his [__] 30s you know and Cay would
just do [__] crazy [__] it was really
entertaining you know
she'd start stripping or dancing or
[__] you know trying to [__] then
she'd kick his ass and try to like beat
him up and pull him out of bed and you
know then she'd go back to [__] doing
[__] like
trying to squat on his head and [__]
you know trying to [__] on the back of
his head and [__] you know did she go
tell you to go get her a [__] drink
out of the [__] get me the Vodka out
of the freezer and I went and got the
Vodka out of the freezer and found a
frozen cat in there and I was like what
the [__] man what's the cat doing in
here I'm like oh my god did I suddenly
get transported into the movie May or
what
happened and and she goes yeah yeah the
cat died and I was like what the [__]
it doing in the freezer and can we
elaborate on that a little bit why is
this did you not why did you not bury
the PO candy well cuz it was frozen the
ground was frozen outside they're in the
middle of the city okay fair enough and
he didn't want to throw the cat away
okay well I get that but that's what I
mean that needs a little elaboration is
well I'm giving it elaborating right now
I didn't have it get I get it I [__]
open up the freezer to get the [__]
still messed up though to get a bottle
of vka out of there there's a [__]
cat laying in there man a [__] rock
solid and it's the it's the cat that I
recognize as his cat
what the [__] is the cat doing in here
oh the cat died well obviously yeah but
yeah the cat died that's what the [__]
is it doing in the freezer just he
didn't want to throw it out and we
couldn't bury it because it's frozen
outside you know it's all concrete [__]
okay okay that's fair enough so we have
to take it somewhere and bury it that's
still weird but it's like at least they
have a reason yeah and I was like how
long's it been in there and she goes
only a few
days but you know I just I was just like
I'm not sure what I would do in the same
situation that's like really upsetting
cats in a freezer that's upsetting well
the cat was clean enough to be on the
[__] couch and be walking around so
they just said we'll just put him in the
freezer you know they had him up on a
freezer rack like I said I get it I get
it I do keep him Frozen so he wouldn't
it's weird but it's I I think I think I
just have to say no I'm gonna have to
throw the cat
out see I don't know I don't I'm not
going to keep cat in a freezer I don't
know if I could do that it's like I
don't know it would that's like I said
that's it's kind of a hard decision yeah
it was an old cat it just died old age
old cat just like you know I remember
when that [__]
happened we have three fur Daughters of
our own so yeah it's kind of hard to
think
about Mr ad said Thomas man labora man
elaborating like elaborating but like
man elaborating well you see the way a
man tells the story we tell you what
happened and then I go back and [__]
tell you what it was like they tell I
come back and then I tell you what
happened again and then I go back and
describe it that then I tell you what I
learned from it and then I tell you what
you should learn from it that's a that's
that's how and then they turn around and
tell you that women talk too much yeah
and
then women don't know how to tell a
story okay even though men will go on
for hours and hours and hours about one
thing but you know what I mean I'm just
saying you want to uh more more to drink
yeah why not it's Friday night we're not
going anywhere okay I mean you know we
were at the biker bar earlier but I was
um Zach couldn't be here tonight because
he was he he texted me earlier and said
oh I can't come to the show tonight cuz
he had some other [__] to do but um I
was like yeah I'm in a biker bar right
now and Night Ranger was on the jukebox
it was Sister Christian and I was just
kind of like H which okay but I was kind
of like complaining about that but then
like somebody I don't know who it was
because you can pay to like put stuff on
the uh juke box but I don't know who it
was cuz there was a bunch of other
people there so after that I was just
kind of like okay whatever Night Ranger
but then like all this country music
came on cuz prior to that it had been
like okay it just been like Leed
Zeppelin and stuff and Jimmy Hendricks
and I'm just like all right I'm all
right with that but then like all this
country music came on and I'm like oh no
oh no is this the direction where we're
going in now but then it was like three
or four country songs and I was like oh
my God please kill me but then somebody
put nxs on and I was just like okay I
don't love nxs but at least it was one
of the two nxs songs that I actually
like so I wasn't all that upset about it
but yeah so I was we drank kind of a lot
like I said we um we were there cuz a
couple of our friends were there on the
way to Daytona for biketober Fest we
Haden seen them in a long time and
they're apparently moving away so we
wanted to see them before they moved so
that was kind of fun but um Bryce says
from what I've seen there's a big
difference heroin addicts die way early
oh because Camp guy asked what's the
difference between a heroin junkie and
an alcoholic or a pothead big
differences yeah that's what Bryce said
um big difference heroin addicts die way
early I've known a lot of strippers and
prostitutes hook on junk that died yeah
that like I said I in my in my
experience um you know just people that
I've known and people that I've heard
about and stuff people that are addicted
to heroin they either die real early
like in their 20s of a overdose of an
overdose um if they live like yeah they
might turn out okay but they usually
don't um
alcoholics burthe heads it depends on
how early you start and how much of it
you do alcoholics tend to burn out fast
and they look like [__] by the time they
hit the 40 they look I mean they don't I
don't think they and then they fall out
of the scene you never see them yeah I
mean some of them die kind of early like
from you know if they're real alcoholics
yeah they'll they'll die from like
[__] yeah like in a wreck or you know
therosis of the liver or something like
that but some people can be like just
mild alcoholics for quite a long time
yeah but they'll just look like crap in
big cities female alcohol
end up dying as lesbians which that was
a weird thing that [__] was happening
when we were there [__] where I was
there [__] um usually they were kind
of like
strippers uh they couldn't hold jobs
they couldn't really do anything because
they were just such bad
drunks dudes didn't want to take care of
them they got sick of the they dudes
would pass them around for a while and
then they would end up getting no I
don't want and then they would end up
going to lesbian bars and going there
and then those girls would run through
them uh then they wouldn't make it a lot
of them dead by 40 weird yeah that's why
there's a stereotype that lesbians
[__] are alcoholics that's where it
comes from is there yeah there was a
stere heard there's a stereotype in
Boston the lesbians drank a lot oh that
must be a Boston yeah and lesbians drank
a lot and they didn't tip most [__] I
never heard that either well bartenders
would tell you that the only thing I've
heard about people not tipping was rich
people not tipping okay that's the only
only stereotype I've heard but I've
never heard about other people not
tipping in Boston oh and church people
not tipping yeah like on Sundays when
they come there after church like a lot
of them don't tip that's I don't know if
that's true but I've heard that from a
lot of restaurant people stereotypes in
Boston of Les of the lesbian crowd was
that they
hi they didn't
tip um they were they drank a lot a lot
of violence they fought a lot fought
each other a lot yeah I mean maybe
that's true but that might be Boston
specific I yeah that's just and that was
'90s when I was heing that I haven't
really seen that recently I guess you
say around here but Florida's a very
different environment than than New
England New England is like its own it's
like another country it is another
country totally different country
different different
culture
um and in the 90s lesbians were kind of
divided into male and female gender I
guess it be a good way to put it some of
them just look like girls the other ones
they were like dressing like guys
and alcohol was [__] big in that
scene I knew one I was friends with a
Butch she was cool like I said I knew
some too but it's just like I guess the
scene was kind of different maybe in
different cities cuz I never really had
that impression like I said I wasn't
like super hardcore into it but yeah so
but I did know a couple people in that
scene and it's like I never got that
impression so but like I said different
cities have different scenes so it might
right well Robin I told you about Robin
Robin was a soft Butch she'd hang out at
the [__] goth clubs and [__] and
every now and then she'd [__] wanted
she'd take me home and we'd have
sex I didn't know what the [__] was
going on with that and then she'
disappear found out later on that
[__] a lot of lesbian girls
[__] at certain times of their Cycles
[__] will'll sleep with
guys but I don't know how you know but
that's that's something I mean that
might just be for entertainment purposes
or well of course it's just hormones
right it's when they're when they're
ovulating they'll sleep with guys they
say that that's pretty Universal some of
them if they can now there was another
one that was just other one that I
forgot what her name but it's been a
long time she used to hang out at the
dungeon and she used to sit right next
to me we drink together just like
[__] two dudes and talk talk about
[__] and uh she'd [__] she would
[__] talk about women it was [__]
horrible talk about she was sexest as
[__]
man and she could drink she could
[__] really
drink H interesting yeah she was like
[__]
um women are [__] bches and this and
that she she was like that you can't but
she didn't like guys either but you know
this just weird yeah I'm kind of more
along those lines I don't really like
people in general yeah yeah I don't want
to say that I'm I'm not I'm just saying
I I reserve judgment yeah um my my
default setting is I don't really like
people yeah um but when I meet a new
person I'm like maybe you will be the
one that won't disappoint me maybe we'll
see like I'm I'm giving you the benefit
of the doubt you know what I mean so
it's just kind of like when I meet that
person I don't have any judgment about
that person depending on what they look
like or whatever um I'm just kind of
like wow me like what just just be you
and we'll see how things work out yeah
um sometimes that's sometimes that's
cool sometimes that person is awesome
sometimes that person is a stone cold
nightmare but you never know like I said
so I'm kind of like halfway in
between people suck generally yeah and
I'm not going to judge people until I
meet them individually is that weird is
it weird it is kind of weird I don't
know well like I said I I like to just
give people the benefit of the doubt
like I said if you come at me kind of
cool then cool but if you come at me
kind of you
know I don't know it's maybe it's weird
it's contradictory I get it Danny
rolling said do tomama Jenny carve
pumpkins for Halloween and cook the
seeds we have done we I just cook
pumpkins mostly um we carved pumpkins
last year we have some pumpkins pumpkins
this year some little ones I got
pumpkins I got pumpkin Parade from last
year I got it we still have some frozen
pumpkin because we bought a bunch of
pumpkins last year we carved two or
three of them and then after Halloween
we scraped out all the um all the meat
like we roasted them and scraped out all
the meat and we still have some of that
from last year yeah it's frozen though
and I got new pumpkins I bought yeah cuz
we we make stuff with it we make curry
with it we make pumpkin bread we make
all kind of stuff Mr 8 says isn't
fighting in Boston a matter of course it
was best ESP in the
80s uh but I was there in the like
mid90s and uh it had it had calmed down
some the ones that used to fight a lot
in the 80s were like uh skin heads would
fight a lot we kind of had that too in
Central Florida was a big skin head um
contingent skinheads and punk rockers
would fight each other a lot but those
two yeah we had that too we had that in
those factions kind of vanished over
time um and I'm talking about like ' 80s
and '90s yeah when I was there Boston
was becoming gentrified it was
the the um the rents were going up and
all the
uh what do you call retail space prices
were going way up so everybody was being
kind of priced out so the kind of people
that would be fighting in bars and [__]
couldn't live there anymore
so it was becoming more upper
class um even the clubs that I remember
from that era like [__] Man Ray and
everything they're and and hex I think
it was called hex or hexen been a long
been a long time like like that old
silent movie I think might have been
just called hex did you ever see that
movie yeah that's a good movie actually
and um they're all gone man ra be got
torn down and they built a [__]
bookstore there for a while then that's
gone because I don't know people don't
buy books you know like not like it was
not enough to keep it
open in a place like Boston the rents
are too high
uh Boston is almost kind of like in a
certain way the snotty neighborhood of
New York City right they're [__]
snots man I didn't [__]
I I
liked people from Boston that were born
there and they were like working class
okay like the Italians and the Irish and
[__] they were there forever they're
kind of rough neck and they were a
little bit more I could see more eye to
eye to them most of the ones that I was
dealing with people that moved
there and they moved and they were moved
there to go to the Ivy League colleges
or to pretend to go to Ivy League
colleges that's another thing you have
fake ivy league College people there
they weren't in those schools but they
pretended to you know it was
just it was a cluster [__] um it was a
good experience for like four I lived
there for four years and I had fun but I
couldn't live there for much longer than
that there's a lot of limitations in
what you can do there it's very very
gentrified you're going to be living in
an apartment you're not really going to
be able to own a car a motorcycle you'll
never be able to really like shoot guns
or have any fun like that you're going
to be working in a [__] office you
know the closest thing that I would
consider to be fun in Boston would it
either be a cop or a criminal I I'd like
that the rest of those jobs
I that's like almost kind of like I
don't want to sound demeaning but it's
almost kind like woman's work or
something you know I mean that's like
that's not the kind of [__] that I
believe oh that doesn't sound demeaning
at all yeah yeah saying like [__] that
what do they need somebody like me to do
go into an office for that's like
wasting Talent you know what I mean they
don't [__] oh but it's not wasting
Talent if I have to do it yeah well
you're not you don't have the background
that I have you know [__] so I'm not
as good as is that what you're saying
you're not designed to [__] people up
you know what I mean [__] I like
something that's difficult where I could
probably get killed doing it that's not
in Boston you know I okay I'm not as
good noted it's not as good it's just
different all right you're a civilian I
wasn't [__] raised as a civilian you
know all
right off Tom always tries to say gu
okay whatever I'm not going to talk
anymore we're to we're going to have all
this all this [__] mandry digging in
deeper and deeper okay Tammy says I had
an 18-year-old little dog that I had to
put in our extra freezer for a weekend
cuz I was going to get him cremated and
we weren't open and they weren't open
yeah I mean it happens I get it I that's
what Rich did but the thing is though
that's what I mean it does seem a little
weird when somebody's over your house
and just like why is why is there a
here's the thing get it here's the
thing Rich had that [__] cat in that
freezer when I found it she said it was
there for a couple days that's what she
said I had more of a feeling it was
there for a couple weeks well maybe they
just forgot when Rich killed himself
probably about six months later that cat
was still in
there man that's now the seasons hadn't
really 100% turned yet right but that
cat was in there for a long time and it
wasn't wrapped up it was just sitting
there like it was asleep on the r my God
they didn't put it in a bag or anything
no no no you she just put him in there
like like he was just this little cat
freezing in there you know I you're
your [__] together you know what I'm
saying they didn't they were trying to
be respectful I guess at least I mean I
get it I do he they love the cat you
know the cat the cat could sit on the
[__] couch without being in a plastic
bag so they thought it could sit on the
[__] freezer rack without being in a
plastic bag this is like upsetting me so
much cuz I'm just like thinking about
I'm thinking that cat that cat was L
though I know but it's like I'm thinking
about our kitties and I'm just like I
don't I don't know what I would do and
that's
I just I don't like thinking about it
the cat had been sick for a while and
[__] fell asleep and never woke up
and they found it it was
dead yeah I don't like thinking about
that yeah uh when we were talking about
that cat was like old like 12 13 years
old type D that's not that old cats can
live till they're like 20 or 21 well it
was old enough it died or something okay
Camp guy said I knew a lady that started
drinking and she died within two or
three years and he said I've been going
for decades yeah I'd be in big trouble
if i' well and I mean to be fair I
didn't really start drinking heavily
until I was in my late 30s like mid to
late 30s like when I was in my Teena you
know teens and like 20s and stuff I
drank a little bit but not I would drink
late every now and then I wasn't really
that into it I didn't really start like
drinking a lot until I was in my mid-30s
so maybe I'm okay I don't know um Bryce
says oh wait a minute Mr 8 says maybe
you'll be the one that won't disappoint
me that's gold yeah I I kind of Tammy
said we need a t-shirt that says
that I kind of need a t-shirt that it's
like you know please try not to
disappoint me that's what the shirt's
gonna say You're Gonna though but um but
yeah Bryce says in my experience a lot
of lesbians hate guys I think it might
be because of competition I don't know
um yeah I I don't
know I don't know yeah it's probably
true well there
maybe that one that used to [__] sit
right next to I don't know if I sat next
to her we sat next to each other at the
bar this is at the place called The
Dungeon which was downstairs the House
of Blues [__] in those days it's gone
now but it was at U
uh Harvard Square there was a House of
Blues there and it was a small one and
they had a downstairs bar called the
dungeon was goth as [__] you'd have
loved it Jenny walls were red and black
and it had [__] just like my bars all
the way around it so it looked like you
were in a big cage and the [__] the
the bar countertop had a big painted
[__] landscape of Hell on it and it
had a [__] I like that yeah it had a
whole [__] hell theme I like that and
they had a [__] juke box that had a
whole bunch of morsy and [__] The
Smiths on it and a bunch of other stuff
it was it was all music you would have
liked and you had Goths would go in
there sometimes but it was normies and
Goths and punk rockers and Weirdos you
could go in
there that's my favorite kind of place
yeah I don't remember the girl's name
man she was a little bit older than me I
think by about a year or two she just
was rough looking Butch you know [__]
whole nine yard leather jackets and
[__] 50s looking Elvis hair and [__]
you know she just like that smoking
cigarettes she was cool but I think she
was from prison I think she did some
prison time she had a bunch of tattoos
on her she drank [__] a lot she
didn't have a job
I don't remember when she I can't
remember where she got her money it
wasn't it wasn't panhandling it was
something kind of like that I don't
remember her and her girlfriend were
doing something they were making money
she was always fighting with her
girlfriend ah she's being a [__] she's
doing this I told her just that kind of
[__] you know what I mean and she
doesn't want to do this and that and
[__] those [__] she's like that you
know it's like talking to an angry dude
right yeah I was like I know how it is
man she's like this is like that we're
commiserating
I know how it is man she they don't know
that it's like that kind of [__] I got
you yeah you know it's just [__] like
that but [__] uh what was weird is
that you say that they hate men that
particular one I don't think did yeah I
I never I like I said I've known a lot
of lesbians in my time I never really
got that impression um I don't think
they hate men they don't really think
about men usually right um when they do
they're just kind of like ah yeah yeah
they don't really think about it I kind
of feel like her girlfriend would show
up and she she didn't look lesbian she
was just a fat girl and they would fight
talk [__] to each other and then she
Lees she storm out of there but they
live together right that's what was
going on there now I don't know how long
that lasted I only knew that I only knew
that chick for you know I would just run
into her maybe like six months or a year
yeah maybe like you know once a week
right you know for about a year you know
it's just like somebody you see at the
club right like it's like that you go
there like once a week and you see the
right it's like that actually no I went
to I went to the
[__] I pregamed a lot at the uh at
the dungeon I probably went there three
times a
week you know what I mean yeah I'd stop
off there and get a drink before I go to
the club oh okay yeah so and then
sometimes it was kind of like kind of
like a traditional British pub you just
go down there hang out you know what I
mean and people would come in and out
they were kind of regulars so you all
kind of like recogn knew each other it's
kind of but it was just like only in the
only in the
pub the whole area was like kind of like
all the little Bars were kind of set up
as kind of like Irish Pub type
situations some of them like you said
when you talking about Irish have where
they're serving food too and they were
serving food down there House of Blues
food right you could get a pizza down
there but it was like made
on non breed kind of it was still really
good and it was like only like six bucks
nice back then you know you just it was
a n bread with some tomato sauce and
some cheese and some [__] on I mean I'd
eat that not going just fill you up you
know and uh I was blowing through money
man I was making good money there and
just spending it all like like an idiot
you know spit it all and I didn't have a
girlfriend that lived with me at that
time yeah to help me with the [__]
bills yeah which I should have but I was
kind of [__] stupid because I was
like well why could I have one when I
could have them all that was the
thinking you you're you still kind of
feel you still kind of think you're kind
of greedy you know you're still kind of
you're still kind of talking about a
herum nowadays yes I'm not going to have
I don't need that you know [__] I I
don't I don't need one man [__] you
know what the hell is I want all of them
I want all of them so if I bring one in
here and she helps me with the [__]
rant [__] then I'm stuck with her then
she's not going to let me have all the
other ones well what it is is what it is
you know when you're in your 20s we're
cramping your style Tom when you're in
your 20s you really think you're the
[__] you know what I mean and [__]
you have I know I was in my 20s and met
dudes in my 20s believe me I I know
because you have so much time ahead of
you right you know what I mean you think
well I have not yet achieved my
greatness you know I mean so there's no
reason for me to commit to any of these
women because fcking you know 20 years
from now I'm gonna be such a badass you
know what I mean and then I'll be
[__] 40 and I'll get a [__]
25-year-old girlfriend you that's what
you're thinking yeah of course they are
yeah let me tell you girls something if
you're listening to this program all
right this is out of my personal
experience as a man a lot of you guys
might be out there a lot of these young
women out there maybe thinking about
dating dudes and going out with these
guys and you're single and you're trying
to I don't know maybe get a husband or
something if that dude's about 38 37 38
he's not married and doesn't have any
kids forget it he's chosen his life
something is the matter well it's not M
the matter it's just that he's chosen
his life he's going to he's not going to
get married okay well it's like it's
okay if they've already been married and
or divorced right or something like that
because I've like met well you've been
married before I was divorced without
children right yeah me too but when I
met Jenny I was about 38 I had no
intentions of ever getting married again
yeah and he told me that in no uncertain
terms
yep it wasn't until like 15 years later
after hanging out with this chick I'm
like yeah man kind of [__] her over
if I because [__] [__] we don't have
that much time left and [__] if I die
she's stuck out yeah she done 13 years
of good
service that's yeah I started thinking
about it started realizing [__] it's
like I've already been married to her
anyway yeah it's not like you're it's
not like anything different I'm not
going anywhere that's what I mean so
it's not like you're running around
trying to get a hair well that I know of
no but you know you might be but I don't
no I I don't know I I don't think you
are no but you know no that well all
guys I'm I'm not either see here's the
thing here's the thing you're thinking
it's me no all guys are like that I know
they are they're all like that yeah we
we all know that all of y'all are like
that I'm just honest I'm just honest
about we're we're we're kind of wired
that way uh
but over time you know I mean your
wisdom can realize that well [__] that's
just kind of Impractical you know what I
mean and also that's not really the best
situation for you as a man especially if
you're not a [__]
billionaire okay because the dudes that
actually s did that kind of [__] or do
that [__] have a [__] ton of money so
they have very little to lose through
divorces and stuff you know what I mean
they they're well protected or they were
dudes back in [__] Antiquity like
[__] jagus Khan who had like 600
wives and [__]
uh the the I've seen the [__] data
the natural
[__] the natural situation between
men men and women is kind of like what
you'd see with [__] walruses it it's
harms because women have hypergamy where
they they want to they
will they will actually rather be single
than to be with a [__] average dude
they want to be with an above average
Guy They'll share that dude if they have
to well I wouldn't well you wouldn't but
a lot of them will okay and if you don't
then you don't count because the guys
that have those Herms are the women that
would oh well so it's self- selection
you know what I mean and um I don't mind
not counting
yeah I'm not really concerned about it
women date you either over or over and
up you know they want a guy who has more
than that they have six packs six foot
tall six figures income uh basically
they go out they want a guy who's better
than them they want somebody to look up
to they don't really want an equal they
definitely don't want to date
down and it's just the way women are
built which I don't blame them I would
be the same way the problem is is that
the guys that are the top tier guys them
top 10% of those guys are 20 they're all
going after the same 20% of the guys
depending on whatever age group it is
those dudes are [__] have [__] 10
girls after them so there's a lot of
competition and uh the guys that have a
lot of money their millionaires or above
billionaires have three or
four in some In some cultures it's
[__]
legitimized you know what I mean that's
just the way system Islam everything is
Islamic is like that there's you guy can
if you can afford three then you can
have
three and just they've been that way for
[__] since 700 AD yeah cuz men
running [__] Tammy says I don't know any
woman that would share a man I don't
either yeah they're called gold diggers
all right [__] uh the the those dudes
have them they'll have lots of them but
like I said yeah every woman I know
would not share a man the when I grew up
partially in
Brazil and Brazilian guys who had a lot
of money they were
multi-millionaires had a wife but they
also had three or four
Mistresses and their own apartments and
everything and that was just like well
the thing about that well the thing
about that is that how much of that is
oh well the dudes have some money so the
women are just putting up with it they
don't like it necessarily but they're
putting up with it but they seek it out
do they yeah they do seek it out because
it's a it's a huge move up for
them I mean I wouldn't do that I'm just
saying that it's just kind of like cuz
they the their men in other words their
peer men right are laborers okay making
kind of like the equivalent of today
probably be like 15,000 a year maybe
less and she's
living like she's making
$150,000 a
year so the men of their equivalent
status could never afford that lifestyle
could never give it to
them so no it's just the way it is
Central and South America is just like
that it's part of the culture it's like
professional girlfriends here that's not
as right now that's not really a thing
here it's uh business guys who have a
[__] ton of money they have a wife and
they have a family and they have [__]
escorts they don't keep them around but
they're that's the difference and in
South America they'd keep him around
they'd have him in an
apartment it's a girlfriend basically
Bryce says uh I don't know about uh
hypergamy LOL women are pretty diverse
in my experience mine also but you know
men don't really look at women as uh
diverse uh apparently some want to go up
and others don't care yeah I I don't
care my girl didn't date up she's from a
rich family unlike me Mr R said Tom is a
very meat Market view of dating he does
uh some people do fall in love which you
know I would have thought that been nice
if Tom was in love with me but that not
it has nothing to do with I'm talking
about he's very meat marketing I'm
talking about it's he's very meat marke
it's numbers and
statistics I'm just looking at the the
numbers the statistics and the P which
is a really [__] up way of looking at
stuff life is like that life is pretty
bad it's not though I think it is it's
not though all right you know I love you
that's a sad way of tell her I love her
all the [__] time that's a sad way of
looking I tell her I love her all the
[__] time I know you do Tom but it is
kind of like a [__] up way of looking
at stuff I don't look at other people
like they're me I don't
project I don't either I just I just
look at what the data says no I just
look at other people as individual
people I don't really give a [__] what
the statistics think well no I look at
individuals individuals but then I could
get like a 30,000 foot View and just
look at the whole [__] thing of
what's happening and
yeah it's it's like what the data
suggests there's a lot of
hypergamy women in general especially
certain aged groups when I when I'm
talking about women I'm actually talking
about women of I guess you can say of in
their between their 20s and 30s that's
mostly who I'm talking about ones that
are have not yet married they're trying
to married maybe or they're trying to
have kids those the ones that aren't in
that game you can't really count those
because they're not in that game
they tend to go for guys that are not at
their level but above their level in
terms of just
income uh how they look physically
they're and way above average actually
is is what women like way above average
those young women 20s and 30s will share
a
guy sometimes knowingly good for them
but I would not do that and everybody I
know they're trying to move not do that
either no not all of them I'm not saying
all of them I don't know anyone that
would you yeah I'm not well what ends up
happening is is that the dude's not
marrying one of them what he do is he's
dating all of them yeah but I don't know
any chicks that would do that like not
knowingly anyway they might know they
might like go out with a dude knowing
like that he's dating other people like
not knowing that he was dating other
people and being like oh he's oh my God
like this dude's awesome and blah blah
blah but not knowing that he was like
[__] other chicks on the side oh well
cuz that's happened to me as well but
you know what I mean yeah well when I I
was like oh well okay didn't know when I
was in my 20 when I was in my 20s dating
so bye when I was in my 20s dating that
was the
standard well not only with me but with
the women that was dating they were
dating other people too we're talking
about like when people are dating yeah
um I'm talking about there's a
difference between when you're dating
somebody and you're just like oh well
we're just kind of going out casually
and the understanding is oh well I'm
dating other people casually as well
like I get that as long as everybody
knows what's going on that's whatever
but it's like if one person in the party
thinks that oh well it's exclusive yeah
and but you're still dating other people
on this line you're not telling that
person that's a different situation then
that's kind of [__] up that's what I'm
talking about like I said as long as
everybody is clear yeah about what's
going on I don't have a problem with
anything but a lot of times and I've
experienced this myself uh I know a lot
of people that are that have experienced
this also where you think because of
what this dude has said or something
like that that you are the only person
that they're going oh my God it's so
serious and blah blah blah but they're
dating other people sometimes multiple
other people yeah on the side and you
didn't know about it yeah that's [__]
up okay well it's my understanding of
what I'm talking about maybe I should
clarify it's my understanding that in
these
situations where the guy has multiple
women The Other Women
know like I said if they know and still
choose to do that then that's fine I
mean that's obviously because they know
what they're getting into but if they
don't know that then that's [__] up
they know and that there was never any
promise of
exclusivity that's what I mean but it's
just that he has enough income to keep
them I what's a good way to put it to
keep them [__] kind of like on the
borderline for
years cuz here's the thing a lot of
dudes will do and like I said I've had
this done to me and I've had a lot of
friends that had this done to them where
dudes will pretend you know something
mighten that something's like in there
oh my God I love you and it's like I'm
not like there's nobody else blah blah
blah but it's like meanwhile they're
[__] other chicks on the slide and
like not telling you about it so they're
kind of like leading you on a little bit
and I've had that happen to me I've like
you know I've had several friends that
that happen to so it's just kind of like
like I said as long as everybody is on
the same page about what the situation
is it's like look if you know that
you're dating this Rich dude and he's
[__] you know 10 other women at the
same time and you're okay with
that knock yourself out but it's like if
you if this dude is telling you hey
you're the only person and blah and I'm
going to marry you one day and blah blah
blah but you're still doing that [__]
then that's shitty okay well uh my
understanding based
on based on how it was described to me
what the what these dudes are doing a
lot of them don't talk okay they don't
say exactly what you're doing well
probably it's second it's secondhand no
well secondhand information they don't
give up they don't want to give up their
business you know what I mean it's uh
the kind of sit where it's not 10 women
it's like maybe two three four well you
know I was just I was I was exaggerating
for narrative purposes and what the deal
is is
that he's dating he's not committed to
anybody okay he's still on the market
looking but this motherfucker's got
sports cars and [__] maybe a plane
you know know multiple houses and [__]
and you're dating him he likes you you
like him you're like man I want to land
this dude and he goes you know I like
you so much I'm going to [__] put you
in an apartment that I
own then all of a sudden you're now
living rentree on one of his [__]
apart or he's paying your rent all right
so now you're kind of dependent on him
now you get you comfortable with that
which in a way is a little bit
manipulative yeah but he is he does like
you and he is thinking about it part of
his thing he thinks he's helping you you
start to become but you start to become
addicted to the help well and the thing
is and and I think the thing about dudes
like that is that they know that it's
like if I make these chicks dependent on
me in that way yeah then it's like you
can string them all along Str for a long
time and that's shitty because you're
kind of letting this woman think like
look if you're renting that woman's
apartment you're paying for her to live
she's like oh my God this is like
serious that's what she's going to think
yeah yeah but to him it's not serious
cuz he has a lot of money but it's like
she's going to take it that way so I
kind of feel like even if he didn't say
it outright that's still like kind of
manipulative well he's it's kind of
serious to him it's just not that
serious you know what I mean right but
I'm I'm just saying I'm a big Advocate
everybody just laying everything out on
the table and everybody being on the
same page about [__] it be it would be
like me right giving some chicks giving
some chick 10 bucks a
month right they'd be like that and then
I have like four of them that I'm each
giving 10 bucks a month that's not much
money but to them that would be a lot
all right they're living off Tom loves
me he gave me $10 a month that's what
they that that's enough to buy two
drinks at Starbucks yeah yeah well well
not actually I don't think that is
enough to buy two drinks a half the
dudes that we're talking about right the
dudes that we're talking about paying
$2,000 a month for her rent that's like
that'd be like me spending 10 bucks
right I get not a big deal but to
another person who is in the real world
that's a lot of money if some
[__] yeah was paying my rent
yeah I'd be like oh my God this
[__] loves me or that Ser like I
don't know if I think he loves me
because I'm not that delusional but it's
you know I'm old but I would think well
at least it's kind of serious like he's
paying my rent and [__] like that so I
would think I would have some
expectation in that regard and I think
like a lot of women would even if he
didn't say anything out right well what
what those dudes do all right is that
they might have two or three girlfriends
that they're doing that to and they can
string them along for [__] 10 years
oh exact oh I know and and he's giv them
cars and he's giv him this and they're
like you know what this [__] may
not ever marry me but he's a [__] job
I got cars I got this I got that like
and like I said if that's all you want
and you don't really give a [__] about
it then fine then like I said as long as
everyone's on the same page and
everyone's getting what they want then I
don't have any problem with that kind of
setup the only downside of it to that to
this situation for the woman probably
it's not this these other
women according to what I heard they
don't care about the other women they
just just as long as the money doesn't
doesn't stop
flowing well [__] I was going to say
what what they were really worried about
and it [__] slipped on my head there
there's something else that they're
really worried about what the rich dudes
don't want them [__] other dudes
exactly that's what it is that that
because of course why did I know why did
I know that's the problem why did I know
that because there is a huge double
standard dou the problem is is that the
dude actually expects
exclusivity but he will not give it in
return which like I said that is that is
a big this is a har that is a big
problem this is a Harum okay he expects
exclusivity If he if he catches he
doesn't probably realize that it's a
Harum but it's a Harum now okay if he
catches you dating somebody else he's
gonna pull your funding see to me like
oh we're breaking up that's what's going
to happen see that kind of thinking is
emblematic to me of how dudes like that
don't see the woman as a person with
like agency well they because it's like
they think well I'm paying for this
bitch's apartment or whatever like then
I'll [__] her every now and then or
whatever but it's like oh well she's not
allowed to date anybody I can date
whoever I want though but she's not
allowed to that is messed up yeah that's
not exactly how guys see it though but
that's this is this is how guys see it
I'm G tell you the way a guy actually
sees it man I got all these women I love
them
all that that that's as simple as it is
it's that [__] simple I'm so [__]
rich I I can have five girlfriends I
love every one of them that is
indicative that's actually what's going
on that the dudes do not see the women
as actual people yeah they do they don't
though because it's like if they
actually saw them as people they'd be
like hey maybe they would like to have
some fun too and like go out and do
their own thing but it's like they don't
see it like that they're just like no
they're going to be like she's cheating
on me yeah that's right that is
ridiculous that is ridiculous that's
just the way dudes are I know well yeah
I know that that's why they're [__]
stupid I'm just saying that's stupid
that's really stupid now some dudes some
some dudes can kind of over overcome
that but then they're then they're like
[__] well what am I now I'm a s
[__] you know what I mean cuz that
would be
ridiculous out by this other dude [__]
that I'm pulling I mean we were we were
talking about this [__] the other day
and you were like if you had your
brothers yeah you would have a Herm most
men would which well that's what I mean
you probably would it's not it's like
when I said at The Superficial level for
a man it doesn't seem to be when I said
we oh well can I have a herum of men too
you were like oh well I'd have to
approve of that I'm like hey wait a
minute oh well suddenly I have to have
permission well here's the thing here's
like you don't have to have permission
but I do
[__] up here's the thing this is all
theoretical notional said I I don't want
a harm of men that's sounds like too
much work this is this
is but the fact that y'all think y'all
can have it but we can't is like
hilarious first of all this is all
theoretical notional [__] it's all
notional [__] it's just theoretical
ridic I don't have a her okay I'm just
you would like to have one but you do I
think most men would but then but then
you try to think about what the
ifications and the difficulties involved
you know I mean it's just like you're
talking about there's going to be a
bunch of difficulties so it's it's not
very realist it's not realistic well
obviously that's why most women wouldn't
want them because it just sounds like a
[__] headache for something there's
something about men where some about men
where that's I think that's kind of
programmed into a lot of guys they where
they're like Well yeah if I love woman I
I love a whole bunch of them right it's
not and it's because I guess we
inherited a survival instincts and rep
reproductive instincts of like spreading
seed it's like another way of of making
sure in other words some of my ancestors
didn't have the thinking of meting with
a one woman they were just [__] all
women trying as as many as that they
could just use that as an excuse and
then no I'm just saying I think it has
to do with like epigenetics uhhuh sure
so there two two different strategies
there's like a fast life strategy and
like a slow life strategy the fast life
strategy is just to get as many women
pregnant as possible the slow life
strategy would be to like choose one and
[__] support her and have a family of
multiple kids they both kind of do the
same thing but it's probably back in
real primitive [__] SI situations
probably more of an advantage is to just
run around and get as many women
pregnant as possible well it's uh and
you don't have to do anything you have
to do anything you're just and then
those other than like you [__] a chick
for a couple seconds and then like you
run away and [__] another one you don't
have to like do anything right and if
and you know if half of them die cuz
you're not supporting them doesn't
really matter because you made 30 of
them so that's still 15 15 of them
survived so it's probably what was
happening in prehistoric ages to where
guys are kind can run both programs I
think that's what it is guys can do
either women can't because to have a
child's a lot of biological resources
it's a lot of problem a lot of work you
got to grow a kid this that then you got
to take care of the it's just that uh
our ma male ancestors didn't have those
problems their problem was is well how
many women can I get pregnant that's the
problem not how many well live life on
easy mode if you're into video games
it's easy mode no um I don't think so
because if you actually look at the
numbers dudes in general didn't live as
long and [__] were because they did
stupid [__] well stupid [__] happens in
in nature it's just stupid [__] yeah
well I'm saying they they do stupid [__]
here's the thing here's the thing that's
very frustrating for all men to hear
women think that to be a man it's
[__] great it's just so easy well
it's easier we're saying it's easier no
it isn't yeah it is the average woman is
pretty valued by Society she has a lot
of friends she's [__] worth something
the average dude is [__] worthless
he's a [__] drone he comes and goes
and gets killed and get SS off to war
dies and nobody gives a [__] the average
dude [__] is a drone okay the average
woman sees the average dude as a drone
the man's life is a lot harder because
you're [__]
disposable very disposable women are
like less disposable because they can
have
children you know yeah so no
it's dudes are the guys that you put
down inside sewers to [__] clean
walls inside sewers they're the dudes
that you go to [__] you go and send
them to another country to go kill some
other dudes who are just like them so
you can have your sex Island D dudes are
very
Expendable uh average ones the only ones
that aren't Expendable are the ones that
women looking at those that top 10% well
average people are expendable yeah but
even the average women is Le is is is is
more precious than the average dude they
just are it's a women Children First
mentality even with men
okay women think that men have it made
because women only see and only look at
the top [__] percentile of the men
cuz that's who they want to [__] mate
with Rich dudes who look good who have
all these women and life is [__]
supposedly easy for them that's only the
very top of these [__] dudes the
dudes that have power the average dude
has no power he's a drone yeah but the
average woman has no power either I
don't have I don't have any power yeah
you do no I don't you a lot you could
you could manipul manipulate your way
through a bunch of dudes and get a bunch
of [__] you're good looking enough to do
it you just didn't do it you're it's not
in you I know you well I don't do that
kind of yeah you don't do that kind of
[__] but a lot of women do that's what a
lot of women just they're just about
that you know that's what so it's like
so like I said I don't have any power
you have it you're just not using it
because I don't do that kind of [__] why
would I do that to gain power and wealth
you must be evil that's why all that's
why all powerful people and I don't want
to be are evil I don't I don't aspire to
that I know you might but I don't just
being realistic I don't powerful people
are and who are powerful and successful
and Rich are evil they got that well
yeah they got that by competing against
other people and destroying competition
all right and just [__] they're very
Cutthroat all right sorry I just can't
do that I just can't do I'm just not
that kind of person right well the women
that are in that same game are equally
as ruthless you know it's just it's a
different strategy that they're using
well those people are like not anything
like me so I'm not really like worried
about it yeah that's I'm saying don't
project don't project I'm not projecting
well just cuz you're a good person that
doesn't mean other people are good
people well just cuz you're an evil
person doesn't mean Everyone's an evil
person I didn't say that I didn't say
that talking about the people that I'm
talking about no I'm just saying if
you're accusing me of projection then
you also project Jen used to tr me
before me and Jen were going out she'd
be trying to protect me against evil
women when I knew they were evil they
were better than the ones I was having
before because I'm just used to women
being that
way yeah I know they're evil but that
was part of the game well he didn't
believe me that I was actually a good
person I feel like well it didn't matter
cuz I you know I was going to mess with
that one yeah it was just nothing it was
nothing that was out of the ordinary and
it was nothing that was this is why
women find dudes super
frustrating they're just
frustrating right as [__] I was like
they really are yeah I wasn't taking it
but even you would say that I wasn't
taking that
seriously you know I knew exactly what
it was yeah I know you did yeah but it
didn't stop me from doing it because I
didn't take any even serious I was like
this is going to be fun well I'm sorry I
tried to help you then no you did listen
to her listen no I'm just saying
shouldn't have bother that's that
H did you earn points with me for that
yeah you did Conor earn some points you
well I shouldn't have bothered trying to
help you like I said sorry I care about
it didn't it didn't it didn't save me
because I did it anyway that's what I
mean I did it anyway it went went right
on but yeah uh but no you protesting
going don't do this that chick's [__]
terrible and I was like yeah yeah I know
yeah yeah but that was just the way it
was you know I wasn't I didn't care and
you're really not any better nowadays
which is why I still don't ever trust
you ever what you talking
about because you're just you're still
like that you're still like that I don't
think so yeah you kind of are [__]
like I said I try to help you
but why bother
really you're [__] hilarious because
you're just you know you're just like
whatever doesn't matter I'm just gonna
[__] whatever you listen to her listen
to that's not true I this [__] F I have
never [__] cheated on you I know you
never all right [__] we're you know
and we're married now so you know no I
ain't go nowhere don't worry about it I
just that was back then too that was a
long time ago that's true well like I
said you have to think how I was
thinking back then I'm like what the
[__] am I even wasting my time
like caring about this [__]
because it's like he's just kind of like
whatever I'm just going to [__] her
anyway you were just like that and I was
just kind of like okay I H nothing lose
that's what I mean so I was just like
all right why the [__] should I care and
that's why I started going out with that
other dude that's all
right I'm like well I'm just going to
bang you weren't a thing I'm just going
to bang this other dude then
because and honestly I kind of like kind
of wish that it what that I kind of got
with that other dude oh he was like a
lot nicer than you oh listen to her
listen listen to how she does [__] okay
all right he was a lot nicer than you
yeah where is
he I don't know I just talked to him a
couple weeks ago actually is he married
no so he's available oh I don't know
about that AV I don't know so you're
you're going to get you a new boyfriend
get you a new husband no I'm just saying
okay that was a long time ago that was
like long these women man I'm just
saying trying to make me jealous he she
gets jealousy trying to make me
I know your game you were kind of you
were kind of a jerk about that of course
back then of course just back then you
were a jerk I didn't care you're still
kind of a jerk but you were like you
were more of a jerk back then I'm just
saying I don't I don't apologize for how
I was back then because it made perfect
sense yeah made perfect sense with my
[__] everything that I thought in the
background and everything that it made
perfect sense to me it
did I give a [__] I give a [__] man yeah
I know you didn't I know you didn't
didn't care it I didn't care it but you
know we knew each other but we weren't
that good friends back
then no we didn't only known each other
a couple months uh okay maybe a year
maybe yeah it had been a while it been
that much
okay Daniel rling said someone should
remake the film The Stepford Wives uh
news flash they did um uh what's her
face was in it Nicole Kidman was in it
and it was awful um but maybe they
should remake it again with a Twist like
the family that moves in next door is a
robotic family test parent the
government actually that's a good idea
the
Remake what were they thinking with that
I think I saw it in the theater and they
started like they decided to make it
into like a black
comedy and I mean the original was kind
of a black comedy sort of in the way
that Rosemary's Baby is a black comedy
which it kind of is but not really and
um Rosemary baby was not a black com It
is Well the book If you read the book
it's a lot more apparent okay in the
movie it's a black comedy but it's very
very very subtle yeah um admittedly it's
much funnier if you're a Catholic um
there's a lot more of that in there but
um Stepford wiv same thing like the book
was actually like much funnier than the
movie was the movie was kind of funny
but then they remade it and then they
made it almost like an more overt comedy
and I was like not about it not about it
and I know it's like really hard to
Market
black comedy or something like the
original Stepford Wives from the 70s
which
was a horror movie but it was also like
kind of funny but it
was and that's not an easy sell because
I think that like a lot of people are
either like well we want it to be funny
or we want it to be like overtly horror
and it wasn't either one of those things
so I don't know but I don't I don't know
what they were thinking with the with
the with the Remake I just I really
really did not like it I might rewatch
it at some point because I was like
maybe I was just in a bad mood when I
saw it but I really did not like it at
all like the Remake the Nicole Kim one
and I don't remember when that came out
2000 mid 2000s I don't remember when
that was is going work what are you
trying to do I need power oh I get some
over here what are you trying to plug in
cuz this shit's going to die if I don't
plug it in oh you're yeah what you call
it your tablet yeah um they're talking
about demon seed we did a review of that
a long time ago I love that movie that's
a good movie actually it's a kryon flick
yeah I like that I got it on Blu-ray
yeah we reviewed it like a while back a
while back Camp guy said scary for me
was fantasm I love the original fantasm
actually all the original all the
fantasm movies are good all five of them
yeah I think there's five right
yeah I saw the second one in the theater
I didn't see the first one in the
theater because that was I was a little
too young but I saw the second one yeah
what you doing Pokey hi Pokey
but yeah I
mean I don't know I I don't I don't mean
to be a butthole or anything like that
I'm just I'm just saying all the [__] we
were talking about before Oh what were
we talking
about he forgot in the two seconds that
he walked into the other room oh yeah I
don't know I find dudes very oh talk
about that yeah I find dudes very
frustrating dudes are very frustrating
don't worry about it um in
general you know what I mean I don't I'm
and and I get like more impatient as I
get older and I didn't really have a lot
of patience to start with cuz I'm you
know uh you know so it's just kind of
like when you get to that point it's
just yeah having to deal with it is just
it's it's hard it's hard it's hard deal
with me it is hard well it's hard
dealing with dudes in general they're
just like they don't make any sense and
it's just make perfect sense they don't
sense and it's like and the funny thing
about it is that they think they're the
ones that make sense and that we're the
ones what don't make sense because dudes
think of themselves as the default
that's why they think of themselves as
the default so everything else is like a
deviation yeah so like the way women
think is a deviation apparently I don't
really think so even though that's not
how I ever thought of it I mean you know
even though we're actually women are
actually the default sex you know that
right the default gender the default
gender yeah all the all um little
fetuses are female yeah men are like the
improved option they're like we're going
to I do not agree see this is how I spin
this [__] I can spin it just as much as
Shee I ain't worried about I do not
agree just the um I um you're the
simplified version
no yeah he doesn't care about that Tammy
says preach Jenny this just win and
talking yeah what we don't matter we
don't matter no we're just like cars
we're just like cars or objects talking
they're talking a dude would want a
whole garage full of women just like he
would have a whole garage full of cars
cuz we're just OB
that's only one aspect that's only one
aspect thank Jeffy art what's that okay
have you guys thank you have you guys
ever done an episode about the secret
societies or the Dead Sea Scrolls I
don't think we have actually we've done
like a couple secret society shows but I
don't think we've done one about the
Dead Sea Scrolls but that's a good idea
actually Dead Sea Scrolls actually kind
of boring I can no it's not I can almost
swear you both have at some point yeah
know freaking I should write that down
though because I kind of feel like that
might be something we want to well I
could make a show out of they're from
that look th those those are not from
the Bible they're from that time but
they're kind of like and they may they
may be from the same
universe you know like it's like the MCU
like like that but they're just the more
of them that they translate they're not
really all that big of a deal it's just
more Gnostic writings kind of deal from
that um but I don't know some people I
guess they don't have much to do with
the Bible but like I said it might be
kind of an interesting show though like
kind of delving into what's in
there you know just saying yeah it's
just they're just similar writings
yeah there was a lot of that there was a
whole industry of making [__] holy
writings I it was like an
industry didn't mean that they were holy
just that that's a um that's kind of
like a genre of literature that they
were doing back then
yeah Victor says are y'all going to do a
spooky story episode like y'all did a
while back yeah cuz our next episode
would probably be like the Halloween
special um I want to resubmit my story
you can like I don't know what the next
subject is going to be I put up some
kind of like we've kind of run out of
like Halloweeny topics but I did kind of
put some up for the next poll so but if
you want to submit a
story um I can absolutely like read them
and we can discuss them on the next show
because like I said it'll be preh
Halloween cuz I think the yeah we're
going to do that show and then the next
show will be after Halloween so I guess
the next show would be like the
Halloween show but yeah I was going to
say something or answer one of these but
yeah demon scene oh 2004 was the oh my
God that was like longer ago than I
thought I don't know I just didn't like
it was it Matthew brck was in that too
right I could of feel like Nicole kimman
was in it and Matthew brck and I kind of
was excited to go see it cuz I really
liked the novel and I really liked the
original movie and then when I saw it I
was just kind of like what the [__] what
are they doing I I just didn't get it
but you know I I'd be willing to give it
another
whirl but I just remember really really
really not liking it you
know the stord wives
remake I kind of felt like they missed
the
point of the novel and the original I
mean that's not unusual but I kind of
feel like they missed the point of the
novel in the original movie what was the
point well I mean the whole point was It
was kind of like a black comedy or like
a satire like it's a horror movie but
it's also like satirical and the weird
thing about it Androids weren't they
well yeah but the weird thing about it
and this like this is so strange because
I read some um reviews of The Stepford
Wives movie when it came out back in the
70s the one with uh Katherine Ross and
some reviewers who apparently are um not
all that bright thought that the movie
was making fun of the feminist movement
and I said it's not making fun of the
feminists it's making fun of the dudes
in the movie it's making fun of the
dudes in it's
sterzing the idea that that's all that
dudes want is they want their wives to
be robots that will do whatever they
want and look the however they want it's
sterzing that idea it's not sterzing the
women the women were or the heroes or
the sympathetic characters at least
that's how I saw it and I thought that's
how everyone else saw it as well but I I
didn't see it apparently not I can't
really comment I I didn't see it you saw
that movie we reviewed it a long time
ago and I read the novel as well the
novel is really good by IR 11 if you
haven't read it he also wrote Rosemary's
Baby like I said oh and he also wrote A
Kiss Before Dying which is also really
really good they made a movie of that I
don't love the movie of that as much but
the novel is really good but um yeah I
didn't really get why critics at the
time in the 70s thought that was
satirizing the quote unquote women's
movement I was like it wasn't it wasn't
starzing that it was starzing the dude's
attitudes toward the women's movement is
what it was satirizing yeah they
obviously but anything you do can be
interpreted the almost the opposite well
that well that's the weird thing like
some critics got it but I was just like
some critics reading I'm like did you
see the same [__] movie or were you
even paying attention or what people's
brains work differently I guess not
people's brains work differently I me
see the Chalice or you see the two faces
looking at you neither one's real
there's there are two faces but there's
also a chalice you know I guess they're
both kind of real depending on how you
look at that's probably what is uh I I I
think the whole thing's laughable
because they're worried about sex bots
you talking sex dolls that can work
that's coming that's coming probably
yeah
um the thing is though is I I kind
of I kind
of uh kind of had the feeling
that dudes will be disappointed with
that yeah let's kind of get into that
because that was this is one thing and
maybe I don't know was I was going to
say this is TMI but Jesus Christ there's
no such thing on this show cuz we have
considered for our streammate show yeah
I was just kind of like maybe we should
get get I mean they're expensive I can't
afford it right now but it's like maybe
we should get like a female like a sex
doll cuz we could do stuff with that
like for the show well you wanted a male
one too cheap but the weird thing about
that is that they don't really make
really good I mean maybe they do but we
couldn't find it like the male ones are
just a weird torso that's smaller than a
normal torso with like a big dick on it
now some people are going like what the
[__] you guys talking about there's a
whole genre
of porn scenes with women with these
fake dolls okay some sometimes uh male
or female but mostly
male and there's a [__] very simple
reason why you you're seeing that now
you don't have to get authorization you
don't have well yeah because that's not
another person because if you've never
done right porn like we have you have to
verify everybody's ID wow it's a pain in
the ass you really have to everybody has
to take pictures of themselves with
their driver's license and it Tak like
weeks to get authenticated and [__] like
that like to even show up on camera
because they want to make really sure
that nobody is underage so it's a huge
pain in the and the AI looks at all this
[__] and every single time we stream on
stream it every single time every day
you have to they have to take a picture
of both of your faces and they AI both
of your faces and make sure that you're
authorized before you can even go on
yeah every single time it knows what
your voice sounds like it knows
everything and if you move somebody into
screenshot that is not a face that it
recognizes you can shut your screen yeah
they will turn you off I once thought
about putting Spock back there that
[__] cut out of Spock oh [__] nope
yeah they would probably yeah like oh
that's an unauthorized person'll go who
the [__] is that and they'll shut the
stream down so we thought about it's
like well maybe we should bring in like
um like a sex doll of some kind yeah so
it's like we thought about faster right
like yeah because it's not a person so
it's just kind of like so you could do
whatever you want they got some
fantastic dolls out there and they have
some that almost look like real people
better or yeah better some of those
human could never be shaped like that
but the weird thing about it is like you
know the women ones and I and I get it
like the audience the like the the
market for the female sex dolls is going
to be like larger than the ones for the
male sex dolls I get it but it's like it
seemed like the once they were selling
cuz we were just like like L on Amazon
and [__] like that and it's like so the
female sex dolls they had these
fantastic ones they like they're $800
$900 they looks like super super
realistic some of them have like heads
you could change out good ones are about
four grand though in case yeah so like
you could change out different heads and
stuff but the male ones the only ones
they had they didn't even have like they
didn't have arms they didn't have legs
it was just like a torso that was
smaller than an actual person's torso
and a big ere dick that was all they had
and I was just kind of like really
that's it and girls are using those
right but it's like making videos with
that [__] yeah and I get it because it's
just kind of like but I was just like
the dildo yeah yeah it's the thing about
it though is I feel like the price point
is too much cuz it's like look you could
just have a dildo I mean it's
essentially just a dildo with a
miniature chest on it right and some
guys might be why don't you just use Tom
because certain platforms don't allow
like for instance streammate doesn't
allow me to appear in video with Jen
even though we can stream we can stream
live but we can't I I can't appear but
he can't be in the video there's some
kind of legal stipulation about about
[__] who owns the who owns the the
channel that's one that's one issue
another thing is is that big part of the
mail Market there is a big part of the
mail Market where the guy that's buying
the product doesn't want to see any
living man in frame because it's
competition right against him so he
wants to see just a
girl and he's going to imagine himself
in the place of that [__] dummy
that's what's happening there this is is
a mind [__] man porn is a mind [__] it
is yeah it's not real it's a product
that you make and you're playing on the
fantasies of men
basically me being a man I'm good at it
because I know what they're looking for
women in general don't have game they
don't know they don't really know what
guys are thinking well we don't usually
watch that anyway it's not enjoyable to
us so right in general like some people
do I know like some women do I know but
it's just like a lot of it to me I like
some of the animated stuff and I like
gay porn and I like certain I like
lesbian porn and stuff but it's just
like a lot of straight porn I just don't
really like it yeah it's not right
particularly interesting it's not
targeted towards obiously targeted
towards a male obviously and everything
on there is [__] [__] that works on
the male nervous system and the and
everything's
visual it there's psychological [__]
going on in there but that part that
part of it is Visual and and
and
uh words [__] dudes up pretty bad too uh
depends on what you say and the
timing untrained women aren't good at it
trained women are they're all important
or they're all [__] escorts and
they're they they know more but the
thing is those those women are not doing
really what they like they're doing what
dudes like well yeah they're just trying
to make money they're not doing what
they want to do yeah and their job is to
get this dude off as soon as possible
and it's easier on them if they get him
off fast yeah so they they want to
know the codes and the [__]
strategies how to [__] these up all the
[__] you got to say and if
you're mentally and emotionally
dispassionate where you're not really
involved in this you can see it
analytically like a guy can it's a lot
easier a woman's going to be emotionally
involved which actually a hindrance for
her ability to do it
like
we're in a
scene live cam to cam and I got a male
client in there who's enjoying the show
and I know he's bisexual I'll [__] that
dude's up I I I know what he's thinking
and [__] I'll say [__] to him it's
play acting you know what I mean but I'm
an actor and I'm a professional about it
you know what I mean [__] I want him
to come back as a customer so I'm going
to give him a good good experience so I
say all kind of crazy [__] to him you
know what I mean and [__] that
[__] will just lose it you know
I don't even think a gay dude could do
that because he's emotionally invested
in the situation he's not seeing it from
a from a detached third person I'm
seeing it almost kind of like a
machine but I can relate though to what
the guy's thinking and what he's seeing
cuz I'm looking on the screen and I'm
seeing what's coming through the camera
what we're shooting
I can see him a little bit but just a
general outline my vision isn't that
good in the photo the video that you're
seeing if you're going cam to cam on
most of these platforms is only like 3
and a half inches by 2 and A2 inch it's
small it's not full screen there's a
bunch of data happening so I can get a
general idea of what he's
doing but it's not really detailed you
know I had to put my glasses on get up
close to see what's going on and I'm
really really into that I got all the
[__] I do I got to shoot the [__]
video I'm shooting a point of view
[__] [__] around with Jen and
doing all this kind of [__] Jen's
[__] putting on her act and
we're trying to get a good show it's a
show it's we're doing it sometimes we
fake it but in general we're doing what
we're doing I mean if we don't have to
fake it we don't yeah but if we do
sometimes a dude sometimes like a dude
is like hey I'm going to pay like for
like earlier today or yesterday yeah we
had somebody that want yeah like
yesterday somebody wanted a particular
thing and we weren't really ready for it
but we kind of faked it yeah we just
faked everything and he and he knew it
was fake but it was shot I shot it in a
way to where we had plausible
deniability yeah because he's living in
a world of fantasy he's trying to get
off he doesn't need detail he just needs
emotion and visual [__] real
quick and he needs to feel that he's
involved in this and that he's in charge
and he's telling us what to do and what
he's asking us to do is not possible in
a time frame cuz the whole thing only
took three and a half minutes yeah I
think that was the time frame yeah I
can't come three and a half minutes I
can't go anal and do all this [__] in
[__] three and minutes [__] you
can't do that it just takes time okay he
doesn't have the money right he's trying
to pay $6.99 a minute he wants to get it
done about three or four minutes because
that [__] was pregaming when he
[__] clicked on the button to go
private he he was his [__] was in hand
he's ready to go he's he's he's he's in
economy mode yeah so it's not like
you're going to do a [__] half hour
[__] show but you want that money
right you know that could be 20 bucks 20
bucks is 20 bucks you know I'm not gay
but I'm gonna make you that shirt
seriously so and I'm gonna make you wear
it to bike night yeah and see what those
dudes would [__] love that [__] those
dudes would love that [__] they think
that [__] was so funny hey you might
make some money no you might make some
money no they go that's right that's
just that's 20 bucks probably all of
them like yeah I get it back in prison
yeah like I said hey money is money
right I don't be grud that [__] was
[__] funny I don't be as long as
you're not steal I saw that shirt I just
started busting up and I showed it to J
I show I'm like oh my God that was on
teu it was on te that shirt was on
Teo I ain't gay but 20 bucks is 20 bucks
[__] fun that's hilarious yeah that's
hilarious well like I said
hey man [__] is tough all over all right
as love like I said as long as you're
not just stealing money from people that
need it and [__] like that it's like any
way you can make some money it's like
I'm not I'm not judging I'm just
saying but yeah so I don't know it's
kind of a whole thing so yeah so I don't
I don't remember where I was oh I
remember where I was going with it so I
said so we were thinking about it would
probably be better like yeah I might get
one of those weird male torsos one of
these days but I was just like so can we
not have like a body with a head this is
kind of or legs or something this is
freaking all that [__] cost extra money
I was like yeah it's kind of freaking me
out so cuz I don't really like those sex
bots that don't have heads it's I don't
know it bothers me but um the Torso is
only like a hundred
bucks it's like I I don't really want to
[__] a headless person that's like
that's upsetting so um but you know they
have a lot more
variety in the female sex dolls so I
said we might do better with one of
those the female doll yeah well because
we can both [__] with that well another
thing is is that you can get a good one
in the the [__] there's a male
audience for that too that's what I'm
saying so it might be actually more um
cost effective scenes to get one of
those well yeah because like I said like
you know we could do more with that yeah
here's the
thing they got dudes this is some weird
[__] man but I understand it now that I
understand this the porn system the
online porn system
they got dudes their whole thing is to
buy these dolls and make videos with
them yeah but they're making money with
it they're making money with it and
those same dudes also [__] do scenes
with porn stars right they're porn star
and it's because there's a there's a
certain it's a specialty Niche sure a
niche for everything they got dudes that
like those dolls better than girls sure
yeah and if you look at the dolls that
they're looking at no woman could look
like that they're just
no it's it's two c okay one of the thing
one of the ones that they like is that
the doll is EXT extremely
voluptuous and it looks like an anime
character out of anime no human could
look like the eyes and everything it
looks like an anime character and it's
got real glass eyes that look like real
huge fake eyes it's got all that it's
got
teeth it's got hair you can change the
hair you can change the heads yeah uh
the heads come off and then you yeah you
can buy different heads with different
faces on them uh some of the heads are
not human heads they're elf heads with
big long ears or heads with
horns uh so there's kind of some
modularity there uh and some of them
were never made to look human even to
begin with so it's kind of like a
Fantasy character yeah if we got one I'd
probably go for a Fantasy character like
a elf feem that yeah that would probably
be the way to go you know in those you
know in the uh you know in some of those
animated 3D porn yeah where they got the
World of Warcraft animated 3D porn is
[__] good I I like I like it J think
about making it making some well I want
to learn how to do um like 3D modeling
in the animation cuz I'm not real good
at that so it's like that's another
thing that I was kind of thinking about
doing because that looks like a lot of
fun to me right uh but the reason why I
was thinking but the some World of
Warcraft characters they have some dolls
that look like those World of Warcraft
characters better actually
yeah but
what uh the the the the draw with that
is that there's problems with those
dolls if they look too much like humans
to me they look like a corpse I think
they're [__] creepy I just I just
think they're yeah the human ones do
look kind of well that's why I'm so
creeped out by like the dude ones
because it's like why don't they even
have they don't have heads or legs or
anything it's just like a torso and a
dick that's so weird yeah that's why I'm
like so weirded out by like the women
ones that are just like
like a torso that you can [__] and I'm
just like it doesn't have a head that is
like so upsetting because it's cheaper
and smaller you no I get it but it's
just like still weird it's just like I
don't really know it's like it's like
something [__] Ted budy would like
that's what I mean it's like I don't
really think I could get into that cuz
it's like this is like not this is a I'm
[__] a headless person this is really
so what what would probably be the best
is to get one that's not human it's like
a elf and it's [__] uh got big ears
and it might [__] fangs and little
deer antler or something something that
can be changed up to where it's a
fantasy creature right it's not even
yeah cuz Tom has always said if he could
have a sex bot it would not look like a
real person no hell no it would look
like some kind of fantasy creature like
some out of anime cuz if they look like
a real person it's a little bit weird
it's too creepy it's too creepy I agree
because then you feel like you own a
person then you tell to get in a box and
you tell to turn it on that's that's
kind of like to me I don't want to
humanize it right you know what I mean I
want yeah so you want it to like not
look like a person I wanted to look like
a sex toy right you know that you
wouldn't feel bad about like you know
what his job is like putting it under
the bed yeah yeah put it underneath the
bed like turn
off you don't want it to be like Joy
from Blade Runner 2049 where it's like a
real person you don't want it to be a
you don't want it to be a surrogate for
a relationship yeah that would be weird
just see BL see that second Blade Runner
yeah where you'll see the issue yeah
where where he's in love with this
[__] hologram that's and she's not
even yeah she's not even a sex doll
she's like an AI she's just a holog like
a hologram yeah and she's very
convincing you you you're like you you
feel sorry for for for her and she's
like she's a real
person but at the end of the [__]
towards the end of the movie they
[__] they they hit you dead in the
face that that was one of millions
that's not [__] yeah they're all the
same it's just a program it's a program
which is like really yeah and this and
the hero of the show who's a replicant
who's in who's in love with the
[__] hologram he realizes that that
he's real and that replicants are real
Holograms and AI is not real those
aren't people so he he he realized he
was in a delusion so he he chose to give
his life to [__] help real people
yeah and to get the mission
done because replicant were real they
were people well yeah they just skated
around the damn laws to make it so they
weren't slav but they were yeah but they
were real people yeah sure so but the
thing but if you're an AI if you're just
an app you're not real then you're not a
real person as much as you seem like a
real person and I kind of feel like
that's what the whole point of that
movie was yeah so but the whole Stepford
wve thing was is getting back to what we
were talking about that the bodies they
have all that technology they can make
these things to look [__] super
attractive right even if they don't look
like humans even if they don't look real
they can still beat that they can say
okay we're going to make her blue and
she [__] lights up and she can shine
light out of her eyes and she has double
F titties yeah tits and ass that no
mortal woman could ever compete with and
she's programmed she will [__] a dude up
and say all kinds of [__] and then she
could go out and [__] do laundry and
[__] vacuum the [__] house why
you're not doing that she's [__]
taking care of [__] she'll even cook you
at dinner right okay that's coming yeah
because here's the
deal a sexbot would be a pretty
complicated [__] piece of equipment
it
would it would be expensive but it
wouldn't be that expensive eventually
everything gets cheaper well if you're
going to spend that much money on that
thing it better do more than just have
sex it's going to have to do all kinds
of [__] chores and [__] to make it
more clean your [__] house right I
wouldn't have it moow on the
lawn because it it might get it might
get damaged right you know
you want it in it's expensive right you
want it in a decent you you don't need
that thing to mow the lawn because you
could have a lawn mower that's just a
robot you know what I mean then the lawn
and the robot lawn mower just mows the
lawn nobody's on it you know I mean but
a sex body its body would be
made for pleasure basically no human and
they'd have males and females and no
human would be able to compete with them
because they'd be made for that right
good good a good
example was that step Spielberg movie it
kind of sucked what ai ai well it was
Stephen Spielberg and Stanley kubri yeah
I had to see I want to see it again that
was I think that was the last film that
Stanley kubri worked on they had Jude
Law in there playing a male sex bot yeah
what was his name um Joe I think it was
just Joe but I yeah I can't it's been a
while I saw in the theater and then I
saw it another time since then but it's
been a while and Haley Jill osmo was in
thato
and Joe no man would ever be able to
compete with Joe in terms of getting
women one he's not a real man so her
defenses are not as [__] raised by it
and he could come up and change his hair
color depending on what she liked from
blonde to Silver he'd add highlights and
he'd go right into his [__] Spiel and
talk about how he felt about you and
[__] [__] like that be all emotional
and talk this woman into [__] paying
for his Services now I don't know where
the money went the money must have went
to a service that owned him I am cuz he
didn't need seem to need well yeah he
was a robot he was a
robot yeah but uh no if guys like that
existed I don't okay if if you looked at
the context of the movie I think it's
accurate they'd be able to screw any
woman they couldn't take your woman
though they were a robot yeah you know
what I mean he was limited in what he
could do he was only kind of for one
thing
entertaining I wouldn't pay for that
[__] I mean some women would but I I
don't I wouldn't women were paying in
the movie well I know that and I and
like I said I'm not saying that women
wouldn't pay for that I'm just saying
personally I would not pay for that well
his whole thing was is that this was
discreet and clean right that's what he
say you know what I mean that he was
selfcleaning all right and that no one
could ever [__] match no man could
ever match and [__] it would only be
between you two and [__] like so you
know with ultra discretion and [__] you
know the dresen dolls wrot a whole old
song about that called Coin Operated Boy
oh okay yeah how she was talking about
how she wanted oh that's who she was
talking she talking about him no she I
don't think she was talking about him in
particular but she was saying that like
how he how much better than like a real
one yeah yeah well the thing is is that
uh it would be Total
Service yeah like he would only do what
you wanted him to and he wouldn't do
anything to piss you off which like I
said that's very appealing but in the
other on the other hand I don't know if
it would be worth the money well I don't
think he charged that much it still
wouldn't be worth the money because it
wasn't his you know I don't know it's
just I don't know like for me it's like
not super high priority he wasn't a
person so he could give so he could give
selfless service right and uh he could
put the client right in the [__]
center of the attention and and he and
he could he he knew what to say to him
if you [__] watch the movie wasn't so
much what he did as what he said to him
so maybe we should maybe we should do a
review of that because like I I've
actually been wanting to rewatch that
cuz like I said I remember seeing in the
theater and being like ah that was all
right and then I watched it again and I
was like that was right better every
time I saw but I kind of feel like maybe
it's improved with age yeah um so I'm
not sure but I have been wanting to like
revisit it every time I saw it again it
felt a little bit better it made a
little bit more sense yeah maybe we
should maybe we should revisit it his
skill was just basically I said it what
he said to him well that's what he was
built for that was his purpose right
right right right that was his purpose
that gets back to what I'm saying before
[__] like that's coming yeah but I don't
think they will fully be able to replace
men and women because there's a lot of
psychology involved in things and you
would know that that's a robot doing
what it's supposed to do right so it
wouldn't quite have the same effect on
you in other words the relationships
would not be emotionally satisfying I
don't think yeah that's kind of how I
feel about it too because I know a lot
of people are kind of worried about like
all the stuff happening with AI and
everything like that and they're just
like oh my God we're going to have like
these realistic like sex spots and stuff
and they just like replace people but
I'm just kind of like I don't know if
that would necessarily happen I kind of
feel like the only situations where that
would happen was people that were
already predisposed to you know um you
know [__] people I'm just going to have
a sex bot that would have just bought a
sex doll before anyway and just like
treated them like a real person dudes
that couldn't get girlfriends yeah so
it's like any anybody that was you know
you know had had a real girlfriend or
wife or anything like that I you know
I'm not saying they wouldn't interact
with those like sometimes but I'm just
saying that I don't think they would
find it the same experience I could be
wrong I don't really know but I don't
think it'd be the same experience I
don't yeah and and I think it would' be
kind of a sterilized experience or you
could probably have a bunch of mods to
where eventually the thing [__]
pisses you off because she's a bad
person type of deal like ah [__] this
yeah it's like and then at that point
might as well be a real person because
it's like cuz it's like I thought the
whole point of having these was that
that wouldn't happen like you're
supposed to just pleasure me like or
whatever I want to do what I think what
I think will happen is is that they will
end up being um kind of in a situation
where the Perfection kind of works
against it it's not very authentic and
you don't buy into it because you know
that it's a bot right okay so it's
probably a a pleasurable experience but
not emotional
really yeah it's it's going to be like a
simulation yeah which like watching a
porn flip kind of right it's like
sometimes you would want that yeah like
I said cuz we've talked about this
before because I was like well if they
had like you know sex dolls or sex bots
or something like would you want one and
he's like oh yeah but it's just kind of
like he's like I don't want one that
looks like a person though because I
don't really want it to no it would be a
sex toy right it would just be like
having a dildo or something like that
You' be like you be be in bed [__]
[__] you say Hey you come on over
here I'm calling the robot in a robot
Gets In the
Mix is that fun with this and and a
robot might [__] be able to change
gender oh now see that would be
interesting now I'm kind of interested
I'm talking about right the robot
becomes a
Fooda now I'm intrigued now I wish to
subscribe to you see here's the thing
some of those dolls have replaceable
genitalia that can
be hermaphroditic maybe we should invest
in one of those we it could be a female
or a male well then we'd have like a lot
of options you're right more modularity
I'm looking for like more options is
what I'm saying the problem I've seen so
far is that the one that have
exchangeable genitalia the good thing
about it is that they're easier to clean
sure the bad thing about it is that
there's a seam where it [__] plugs in
and out so if in the shot on the camera
it's not it'll show yeah I had to look
more more into it and see what's but
that might be something to look into
because the thing is as you talking
about that doll which I'm open to
getting one and it's about four grand
they're a lot of money but I have credit
for a good one I have credit on Amazon
for that well like I said it would be
the the monthly payment I think it was
about 60 bucks a month that's still kind
of a lot but I'm just kind of like I
don't know it's um get money oh thank
you Victor Tom's pegging sex doll Fun
look at this [__]
[__] well I was kind bch are com well
like I said because we've
discussed um you know for the for the
streammate show we've discussed it's
like well maybe down the line when we
could afford it like we can't right now
because we're not making that much money
on it but it's like you know cuz Tom's
like well you should probably bring in
another girl because a lot of people
like watching two girls make out and
already had some [__] lined up with my
ex yeah and and she has expressed
interest and like well you know and it's
not weird because it's like she's my
friend too so it's not and I love her so
it's it's not weird so um she's cool so
we might get into that but I was just
like well that's kind of a whole Kettle
like we know her so that's not weird but
it's just kind of like you know you have
to get her approved and blahy blah
there's a lot of paperwork that has to
be done like if you want somebody else
else is that you have to pay them
they're performer they're P perform so
we were talking I was like well if they
had a good sex doll that was like
modular that you could like change out
heads or like change out genitalia or
something like that like maybe we should
get one of those because it's like that
would be something that we could do
different [__] with and we wouldn't have
to get like all this permission we would
have to pay them we wouldn't have to do
that kind of thing yeah and i' wanted to
get it roughly Jenny's size so it could
wear her clothes see that would that
would be another thing like we could
dress it in different like you know we
could put wigs on her [__] like that
well actually I think the heads have
hair that you want that's true I I think
it's all installed but the a head is
about $100 hund and something dollars
for a decent head I think sometimes eyes
can be popped out of one and put in
another one so the eyes but that's I had
to look at what what what what it is
that that's actually out because think
of all the options I mean and we have a
lot of options as a couple that a lot of
the single girls that are on there don't
have yeah so I was like if we had one of
those then we would have that would open
up even more pull sh and you see the if
if it was not human looking it'd be even
a greater pull yeah because we could
beat the way a human looks right some of
those [__] things where it looks like
an anime elf or a [__] fantasy
creature it's got [__] deer antlers
on it and it's [__] impossible
proportions and [__] dudes will [__]
pay to just see Jen do a lesbo scene
with that [__] grab his titties and
[__] and that's what I mean like we
could do that kind of stuff we could do
threes Sims with it we could all do
I've seen I've seen scenes where girls
were doing fake lesbian acts with the
dam [__] it was sexy because the girl
was [__] like it you can't you know
it's fake but Jen gets paid just by
[__] stroking a dildo in on a camera
yeah people will tip me just for pay
just for that and they know that's not
real they know that's not real yeah
she'll be [__] rubbing that [__] like
that the camera like that CH Ching D
give out 20 bucks you know cuz he's
[__] loving it cuz he's imagining
that that's him him everything is uh
fantasy everything's fantasy in this in
that
business and that is kind of a kinky
thing a
damn weird ass [__] sex doll that's
what I mean like I said there's so many
possibilities that looks like a [__]
something out of a video game Danny
Rowling said strap-on scene see exactly
like I could even get a strap on like
she thought about she was talking about
that that's what I said like well like I
said there was a lot of options that we
could do with it like you could [__] it
I could [__] it we could like lesbian
you could have straight scenes we could
have three Sims we could have all kind
of stuff yeah yeah and a good one's
about four
grand like I said that's a lot of money
but they offered me a line of credit
true right there on on Amazon had them
we'll have to look through there and
like pick what is the best one we have
to pick one that's about the same size
as me like you said because I have a lot
of clothes that we could put on it yeah
that would you know so it has to have
the same size as or similar or similar
so I would like to the clothes that
would help cuz you could put shoes on
them everything
oh yeah that's another thing yeah you
put shoes on them put everything on them
cuz I got lots of shoes they could put
on yeah but yeah so you dress them up
different every time that way they're
not always the same yeah but it might
like I said it might be a good thing to
look into because you know like I said
we're not averse to bringing in another
human girl yeah like a human person it's
just the money there was another there
was another girl who is also a content
creator that was interested but she
never really got back that's what I mean
we have possibility
like you know we kind of like just
generally said about it but oh guess
what you know what Bill said what did he
say remember that old lady that [__]
wicked old witch [__] Sally
D'Angelo yeah
okay the woman that she's always working
with uh the other one that's a little
bit younger than her in her 50s right
was this the hot tub thing the hot tub
the hot tub the other one that was in
the hot tub witha her right yeah yeah I
remember that Amy did a scene with her a
couple days ago no way yeah and she's
she said she's a cool Old Hippie kind of
Stoner yeah girl and I said what was her
feet and she goes nothing she just
collaborates wow yeah you work on her
video and you and she works in your
video and she's here in Orlando wow
that's nice of her and I said and I said
would she work with Jenny goes oh hell
yeah she'll she'll work with with with
any with any um all right hot hot woman
but she's just an all hippie cheick and
she'll [__] smoke weed and do the do
scenes she's about 60 I mean she looks
good though she seems nice she's cute
yeah she's about 60 we watched some porn
of her her and her friend were were
[__] this dude in a hot tub was it a
hot tub or just like a like a tub like a
bathtub was a big bathtub like a big
bathtub yeah she Sally was like 70
something they were having a they were
having a really good time Sally's like
70 something with these huge implants
she looks like a wicked witch but she's
kind of hot in a way she's looks like a
Fu she kind of yeah look like an evil
witch she's like weirdly hot yeah skinny
[__] bony looking with big tits and
she's like yeah you a she's kind of
wicked and dominant and she's with a one
that's a little bit younger her that's
the girl we're talking about they were
screwing this uh [__] skinny black
dude who was about 20 that's right yeah
[__] was huge and he's just kind
of like all right huge [__] dog these
two old ladies were like he's like
that's right that's it was kind of
awesome yeah and they're kind of doing
femd a little bit with him yeah yeah
yeah [__] using him up which I you
know I like that yeah I like that yeah
they're kind of bossing him around a
little bit he's like oh good all right
he's like all right I'm de you sit right
there he's like all I got to do is lay
in the tub I don't really have to do
much of it I'm going to lay here and be
13 in I'm just going to my was big man
yeah I'm just going to lay here with my
erection and you girls go to town yeah
Mr 88 says I think to most people a guy
his ex and his current wife doing
threesome internet porn is outside
normal yeah um yeah I imagine it is we
don't really think about it that way
yeah I guess yeah and they're hot too
they're all hot I like them both you
know I don't I don't have a relationship
with her anymore but yeah and like I
said friend of mine a long time ago long
time ago and you only dated her for
about a couple months for just a couple
couple months yeah and she's married now
she's married now she's married to a
dude I introduced him to a friend of
mine yeah he introduced them like after
they broke up and then they got married
we didn't really broke up we just kind
of stop
seeing right it wasn't uh it wasn't a
highly emotional
well she [__] she put it real well
last time I saw her she goes she goes
you know that was hard times back when
me and you met we were in a weird place
I say yeah
everybody I mean she's very aware of
like the situation cuz we saw her not
too long ago we saw both of them not too
long ago and she and she was just like
[__] we were we were there for each
other at hard times but [__] the [__]
didn't work out between me and you it
didn't but she was like it didn't have
anything to do with us though it was
just [__] the world and I was like
yeah she really like I mean um I will
tell you that every time I see her um
she tells me every time she's like I'm
so happy that that Tom is with you and
it's just like please please take care
of him Jenny please take care she always
does that she always does that yeah she
is always like super concerned about
your welfare
yeah I'm I'm hooked up with AA after my
first divorce basically that was part of
it yeah and uh [__] I was still
trying to get back in the game you know
yeah and uh she had she had just lost
her boyfriend yeah so oh and that that's
a whole can of worms we don't want to
get into that because I I know what went
on with that I know all the people
involved yeah yeah cuz the
boyfriend left her for her best friend
so she was [__] and she didn't like
she's like oh my God that would never
happen except that's I told her that
that's what it was yeah he knew that
that was but he didn't really know I
didn't know those people but he was just
kind of like I think this is what's
going on and that's what was going on
yeah and I said and I was like he you he
was with you for that long he's gone
yeah and [__] he's gone and I said he
left you for somebody you know and he
goes no no no he no he left you for a
girl you know he goes no I only know one
person my best
friend yeah I'm say and I go that's who
he left you for he goes no no he would
never he would never do that never a
week later that's exactly who it exactly
what was going on he was [__] her
best friend
it and uh she wasn't right man so she
and we were already dating by that time
it was just like Dayton and we lived
together it was weird okay but it wasn't
it wasn't really kind of like a normal
relationship it was more like friends
kind of watching out for each other but
we didn't really have any kind of like
driving [__] desire to be with each
other it was weird it's like we kind of
had to be with each other cuz nobody
else wanted us type of deal that's kind
of how it felt and uh yeah I get it
neither one of us were into
it but we became friends yeah and then
uh and they're still friends now like I
said we're friends with both with her
and her husband so I just went back hit
the dating scene and
[__] and that's about the time I hooked
up with that Disney princess girl yeah
well turns out one of my buddies got
pissed off at me for going out with her
and turns out
she was he was dating her yeah and she
dumped him for me well him
Tony I I said well I tell you what I
didn't I didn't know she was dating you
I'm GNA hook you up though I'm going to
introduce you to another girl and he's
like no yeah he said yeah yeah and I
introduce you to yeah yeah I said I'm
going introduce you to my ex-girlfriend
at and he was she was there they would
never separated set that day they met
that was it they've been together for
[__] they've been together longer
than we have years longer than we have
yeah they got married yeah yeah they're
married now to yeah now they make porn
and they are in an let's call it an open
relationship yeah they're swingers
they're swingers yeah so they and
they've sent us video yeah I got
pictures of proof where them and all
their [__] girls and [__] they just
go and [__] whoever yeah in the parking
lots and film it and [__] in parking
lots outside the outside the [__]
swingers clubs and [__] now see Bryce
says making video no one here is normal
my girl lets me [__] other girls and
guys so long as she can okay yeah I mean
like I said as long as everybody knows
what's going on yeah you just don't want
to be sneaky right the only thing I
don't like I don't like doing [__]
behind somebody's back that's [__] up
but if everybody has a discussion and
everybody is on the same page yeah or
everybody is present and everybody is
okay with it then it's fine but I don't
really like this whole hey I'm going to
the bar and then you're [__] some
other chick or some other dude or
something like that that's [__] up
don't do that but it's just what
when me and Jen were friends hanging out
she didn't really know all the details
about me and then we kind of became a
thing and then over time she kind of I
kind of let her into more and more about
my [__] history and my background I
was [__] polyamorous I was in
threesoms since high school so that's
kind of like the my normal State I
didn't really take what you would
call monogamy I didn't really see that
as the norm the norm was to like being a
group of friends and you're all [__]
[__] each other you know it was
heterosexual but sometimes it'd be me
and my best friend just [__] throw
down on some chick you know like yeah
you know and they're it's just kind of
normal for
us Jen didn't grow up that
way
but I never
[__] had to sneak around because I
never really thought I had to if I
wanted to do something I'd just do it I
just didn't really have a drive to do it
because when me and Jen started hanging
out I was a little bit older and so I
was a little more aware of other
people's feelings you know so I was like
well if I do that she's gonna get mad
you know what I mean so and not just you
just other girls i' be dating too well
if I do this over here then she'll get
mad right because I know how regular
people are well it's a whole yeah you're
you're kind of opening up a whole C I
know how regular you're getting
everyone's emotions involved yeah and
Jenna [__] like threatened me going
well then I'll just get another guy and
I'm like well who is it so it's not
really the same threat to me like well
if I like him then yeah okay we'll both
[__] out I'll spit roast your ass man
[__] because I'm not really so it's
not it's not the same you know what I
mean because I didn't grow up that way
it was more like as long as I liked
him in not in terms like sexually just
as long as I trusted him that I thought
he was cool you know uh just was never
really
that because it was never anything that
was planned it was always just [__] in
the moment right and we never really
took any of it seriously
you know because there's a big
difference between two people having sex
and three yeah if it's two it's more
personal if it's three it's more like an
entertainment yeah it's just kind of
like well we're just having a party yeah
it's like we're having a party yeah so
it's not really and we have done like
when we shoot porn it's not the
same yeah it's absolutely not yeah right
well threesoms are like that it's not
the same yeah and like I said we've done
a couple threes Sims before like in real
life yeah um with not another dude like
another girl it's not the same actually
with two other girls but one of the
girls was not participating she was just
watching she wanted to but she was
scared yeah but um she was scared of she
was scared of the other girl because she
thought that girl was so hot she cuz
that girl was a lesbian the one that
didn't want to participate was a lesbian
right cute little lesbian girl you know
who we're talking about yeah follow the
show yeah but yeah so that so we've had
that happen Sonia was [__] dropped
dead so she was like embarrassed to
we've had that happen a few times but
that was just kind of like it wasn't
planned it's just kind of like he we're
all out at the club we went back to
somebody's house and we were just kind
of like you know [__] happened this
shit's going down now you know sh [__]
happened and I'm like come on over here
I'm calling the lesbian come on over
here jumping and she's she's like no so
what are you scared of come over here
just watching and I'm I'm like like
son's right there cuz she had a huge
crush on Sonia just she wasn't she
wasn't mentally ready for it yeah of
like because it's public yeah but you
know it's it's it's it's not intimacy
it's more like a a
show yeah it's like I said that's kind
of the difference between like when we
do [__] on streamate because we've done
stuff on streamate where you know dudes
will come on like cam to cam and they
kind of want we have one dude in
particular who really likes to have like
a threesome experience you know what I
mean he likes to pretend that he's there
yeah like that you and him yeah are he's
our best customer he's a good guy he's a
good guy yeah he's like when he was just
there last night too like he's not there
all the time but like every time he
comes there like we're always happy to
see him cuz he's super nice and he's
like always on for a really long time
he's young guy in his early 30s he's a
fitness guy he's [__] sh he looks
great but his whole thing is he likes to
play with couples and he likes to like
him and another dude like you know just
shredding on like a chick yeah so he
really likes that so he likes to like
pretend that he's here and it's like so
Tom's like encouraging him and he's like
saying encouraging stuff and stuff like
that so it's like a whole but he's not
here you know what I mean so so it's
kind of differental it's he's acting it
out right he's acting it out you can see
on the camera he's [__] changing
position and I'm like I like red get in
the front you get in you get this in I'm
getting over here you know he's like all
right he'll change
position yeah but like I said it's
fantasy yeah like I said I'm not really
bothered by that because like I said
it's not I mean he's a cool dude and we
like talk to him on the screen and
because we can see him and stuff like
that but it's just like he's not here
yeah he's not in the play in the house
he's not in the house or anything like
that so we all know him yeah like I
don't don't know him in real life we
just know him from this platform we just
know him from there so it's just like
that's it's not I don't know like I
guess like initially before we started
doing it I thought it'd be weird but
it's not really it's not really that you
get over it real fast it's yeah you get
over the weirdness like pretty quick I
had it's not weird at all I have real
drama training you know doing musicals
and [__] [__] leads and everything
singing and my ex-girlfriend from that
time is famous her name is Mary L Rice
Cub she was like a star of 24 so you
know I had good drama training she went
on with it I I just didn't want I didn't
like the world of acting I didn't like
the people I thought they were fake but
I did like the skill all right it's
acting yeah you're doing the [__] but
you're not doing it for you you're doing
it for the audience yeah you're
performing it's like I'm not doing
anything like I said if I'm not doing
anything that I think that if I was by
myself like trying to get myself off or
something like that like it's nothing I
would be doing it's no position I would
be in or anything like that it's just
it's for the camera yeah it's for the
camera and then Observer right and you
have to put yourself as a guy I'm
putting myself in the observer's
position you know what I mean so and I
know that the the client or the customer
base is male so I'm like well what would
they be thinking right about now what
would I be looking for right now you
know because the [__] that I'm into
overlays overlaps with other guys
there's nothing really all that special
about me we we're all doing the same
thing basically just different routines
you know there's different styles of it
and different style of video
there certain things that you're looking
for you know
like the [__] that's going to be in an
oral sex centered video is going to be
very different than say like suction
pumps a suction pump video where you're
just [__] pumping this [__] out of
some kind of genitalia under [__]
suction it [__] swells up there two
very different
genres but what the Observer is looking
for you got to know what it is yeah you
got to know what it is that they're
looking for and you really only know
that if you [__] watch that for him
yeah and you try to go into that world
of what's okay I see why this is hot
okay yeah all right yeah I bet that does
hurt that hurts but it feels good at the
same time doesn't it yeah let's see what
it looks like okay wow all right yeah W
God man she got big man sucking on it's
just so you know you kind of know what
the Observer his experience is
like and now some of it translates to
females females like that too certain
things but in my experience talking to
females and [__] females like gay porn
or lesbian porn they like that more yeah
I do and I like animated porn because
and even in animated porn like when we
watch a lot of animated porn which I
like because it's just kind of like well
that's not real people so it's not I'm
not worried about it but even then if we
see some animated porn where like one of
the female characters is like in a super
like uncomfortable position I'm like oh
my God that poor girl like she can't be
having any fun and that cuz that's what
I think when I watch Real straight porn
if they have like some woman like
[__] upside down like like that I'm
like that woman cannot be having any fun
cuz that is like super uncomfortable cuz
I know cuz I've been in that position
only the the guy is putting himself in
that position imagining he could do that
that's what I mean but it's like the
guys are into it cuz they're like man
that's so hot but it's like all I all I
can think when I watch it is like that
poor woman yeah she's been upside down
for 10 minutes like she is probably like
in so much pain her head is [__]
throbbing right it's like she is not
having any fun at all so it's like
that's why a lot of women can't enjoy
porn because it's just kind of like
we're watching that going that poor
woman it's like look at her I'm I'm
going to have to amend that though
women can enjoy porn we yeah it depends
on what kind of it it depends on what
kind of it is very male oriented porn is
targeted directly at at the dude's
[__] system all right and porn that
shot that way the focus of attention is
on the girl because that's what he's
looking at when he's [__] doing his
thing okay women aren't going to be as
interested in that no in gay porn the
focuses the dudes yeah if you look at a
straight porn they never really [__]
focus on the dude's face of who this is
what he looks like what does he look
like from the back what's his ass look
like that's not in the straight porn
because those those dudes viewing that
[__] they don't want to see that so the
women want to see the dudes well in the
straight porn a lot of the dudes they're
their quality that dude's not that high
really he just has to be a stunt [__]
he's got to be [__] gith hard his
dick looks good on camera he's tall
enough to do certain things or he's
short enough to do some other things
depending on what actor it is the high
quality guys if they're making big money
here in gay porn well like I said I kind
of feel like they look a lot better well
and the thing about women that watch
porn and I'm like I said I'm making a
generalization here but I feel like
largely if women are going to watch porn
they're more interested in the people's
whether they're men or women they're
more interested in like the people's
reactions or their interactions with
each other like their facial expressions
or are they enjoying it like I that's
why I like a lot of kind of like lesbian
porner like scenes with L girl on girl
because it's just kind of like and
especially ones where you can tell that
they're into it yeah yeah because it's
like I I really
like like I really like that where
they're like you can tell they're really
into it like they're not faking it cuz I
kind of feel like a lot of straight porn
and the chicks are like yeah okay let's
um you know hurry this up you know what
I mean it's just they kind of look like
that to me because they're in a super
uncomfortable position or whatever so
it's just kind of like when the women
are just doing and they're just like
messing around and they're like not
worried about it and they look like
they're enjoying themselves that's like
a lot hotter to me than yeah than a than
a woman that's just like in this
contorted kind of position and the
dude's like just pounding away and
they're just kind of like okay let's
just you know it's just kind of like
that with with the lesbian porn straight
even straight or mostly straight women
will like that because they can
empathize with either one of those women
and like I said like she said there's
more facial expressions and it's just
more more of a kind of a even if even if
the audience was intended to be men a
lot of times well you were you were
looking more for like
like you how do they feel about this you
know what Ian like you want some kind of
human so women will go will look at that
and really it's not just her man all my
ex-girlfriends watch lesbian
porn yeah I honestly if I'm going to
look at porn I like lesbian porn or I
like animated Fooda porn or gay porn I'd
never watch straight porn yeah ever and
then um I mean we do like when we do the
show but I don't watch it on my own yeah
it's just not oriented towards women
yeah it's not interesting to me like the
women always look like they're having a
hard time and it's just likeing yeah
it's just not hot to me and well a a lot
of stuff that guys like is also rough
and that's what I mean so it's like I
don't really like I don't enjoy watching
women going like oh I'm gagging on a
dick or they're like crying or like I
don't enjoy that even though if you talk
to those actresses they're faking that
[__] well yeah of course they are I'm
just saying I don't really enjoy I don't
find that hot watching that even if
they're faking Al some of them uh some
of them actually uh like Bella Donna
like to be a lot of them like to be real
roughed up because they were big into
submission and like I said I'm not
saying that some women enjoy that like
they do but I'm just saying I don't
really like watching that because it
just always looks really uncomfortable
to me and it's just like it's not it's
just not something you want on it's not
like arousing because I've roughed her
up she loves it but it's not something
she'd like to see on por probably no I
don't like watching porn doing that yeah
well you can do it to me but it's like I
know you yeah and it's it's always at
times there context to it I know when
it's coming I know when it was a good
time yeah it's always like a context and
I know you're not really going to like
hurt me for real no it's all games
playing mind games and [__] right and
then uh they they like uh they like gay
porn with dudes because uh in general if
if you look at gay porn uh which I have
I've done my research on that [__]
[__] it's uh those dudes are [__]
shredded well they're a lot better
looking they're a lot better looking
than the dudes generally and it's
because that's where the money is that's
where they gravitated and I would I I
estimate that probably half those dudes
are not really
gay or maybe just buy or something um I
think some of them are I mean you can
tell at least half of them are and what
was weird although sometimes I'm like
cuz that one dude that I know that was
doing that I was thinking
how could I know he was on a lot of [__]
to do it he was [__] on a [__] ton of
trend he would take [__] triix which
is an injectable form of kind of
like uh Viagra you inject it right in
your dick and you're going to have a
hard on for [__] six hours no matter
you want it or not all right they'll put
that which might be good might be bad
depending on dick up over time because
you get a psychological dependency on it
to where if you don't have [__] tryx
then you think that you're not going to
Popa boner which [__] up your [__]
performance when you don't have it cuz
now all a sudden you're worried about it
I don't recommend
tryx um but the uh I was thinking about
it though you know [__] what he was
doing and what he was talking about and
I was like yeah you take all the [__]
but how could you like do that and not
be gay I'm thinking you got to be gay
nah no I don't I don't think I could do
it yeah but that doesn't I mean you're
not everybody not everybody I don't
think I could do that even with all that
[__] chal assistance [__] I mean for
money yeah I don't know if they if they
offered you a whole bunch of money you
might think I'm thinking those dudes are
by maybe we got [__] Victor what do
you think man could a straight dude
actually do that or is that just well
they do or are they just telling
themselves that they're
straight I hadn't done it so I can't put
myself in the mind in in the
mindset because even even that
particular dude he said some sideways
[__] [__] sometimes you know what I
mean me and you can make a lot of money
together like like he's trying to get
Tom and for that was a long time ago
though yeah that was that was back when
I was on Trend and he was on Trend at
that time too Tom was like okay it's
like deal with a werewolf I was like
yeah he goes we can make a lot of money
together me and you it's not like it's
intimacy it's not it's not like we had
to kiss or
anything just the way he said it I was
just like you some gay porn oh no no
no it's not like a kiss or send me the
video yeah but he he's talking about
other [__] I'm like no no no no no
[Laughter]
no Bryce says I research gay porn every
day but he says uh Bryce says I gotta
agree straight porn doesn't do it for me
personally the girls clearly aren't into
it yeah I mean sometimes they are
sometimes they are um and the straight
porn that I tend to like has girls that
look like they're really into it but
yeah I think a lot of straight porn like
the girls just look like I mean even if
they are it looks like they're not
really into it or they're being like
roughed up or abused or whatever and
it's just like I'm not really into it
depends on who you're talking about well
yeah like and it dep it depends on who
exactly you're talking about and what
scene you're talking about uh like like
I said friend of mine's in that industry
his
wife is basically his he films all her
[__] and produces it and
everything and she does some wild [__]
man and he says she loves it
yeah well like I said some people do
yeah say she [__] loves it say she's
just a natural nyfo yeah she'll do
[__] six onone BBC gag bangs and [__]
he's sitting there filming the whole
[__] thing all kinds of group sex and
[__] uh lots of lesbian stuff lots of
interracial her his wife he's white
she's white his wife is famous for
interracial IR porn even cuz it happened
to be her first Studio scene was that
and it kind of caught on she's real
little she's like
4 fo1 she's a little bitty 4 foot 11 so
they hooked her up with like a [__]
6' five black dude you know so this is a
big black dude little white girl all
right and which that's a whole subject
that's a whole [__] thing okay so
that was like her first scene where that
kind of caught on so she kept getting
more and more kind of orders for that
through other Studios and
[__] but she does other stuff too it's
just that that's like one of her main
fan bases was that
black dude's buying
it but she loves it him well like I said
I don't doubt him I don't doubt it I
don't doubt it either like I said I'm
not like I said I'm not I don't like to
like generalize about stuff it's just
like yeah generally women like this that
and the other thing but obviously
Everyone's an individual just because I
don't like something doesn't mean that
other people can't like it yeah some
chicks might be totally into like doing
gang bang porn and be like yeah whatever
no big I'm not into it but you know what
I mean if they want to do it hey more
power to them well he said the same
thing we just said okay
say it doesn't it say it's like a
performance right okay uh she's doing it
she's having fun doing it it's not an
intimacy thing uh it's not like having
sex with say like your boyfriend or your
husband it's it's more like the the
thrill of doing that performance in
front of the camera
and it's just he said she likes doing it
right you know and then the
money there's a monetary reward like I
said I get that so it's not quite the
same situ and all the
[__] being roughed up and [__] like
that it's just like pro pro wrestling
yeah [__] dudes are pulling blows and
[__] they overreact and to make it
look cuz it's all in kind of like
scripted yeah and like I said we've done
that like on the live stream like I said
I don't mind I don't mind in that
situation because like like I said it's
you and I know you and you're not really
going to hurt me you're just going to
like look by but I don't know if I would
like to do that just yeah in like
regular with like randos yeah well those
dudes aren't randos either well yeah I
know that but it's just like it's the
same group of dudes they've worked with
over and over they know you know so it's
not that's another thing you looking on
a
camera you look at these people little
bitty white girl red hair you know bit
[__]
4 foot something big old tall [__]
black dude [__] you look like they
don't even know each other no they know
each other yeah you know I mean they
don't look like there's any like there
would be like it looks like an odd mix
right because it's opposites but
actually like they know each other and
like she knows his wife right that type
well yeah they work together yeah so
that's people can't realize that yeah
these performers a lot of them are
married and you know yeah and they know
the spouses and [__] and then there like
a whole scene of them so it's not randos
it's just like people I don't know it's
still like I said I'm still kind of like
no I I would do you don't want to do it
no I wouldn't want to do it no not like
that like I said because it's just kind
of like look I'll do [__] I don't mind
like being like exhibitionist and [__]
like that like I don't mind doing that
like as long as it's just like me and
you but it's just like I don't really
like yeah it's just too you going over
the top you see here here's the thing
yeah and like and I'm not [__] on
people that do like to do that but it's
a totally different
the people that are doing that are in a
totally different situation yeah like uh
okay here here's the weird thing the the
couple I'm talking about and it's um I
can I can say their name uh it's [__]
um the uh like I say the stage name it's
the husband of Amy Quinn you can find
her on Twitter all right Amy knows us
even though we've never talked to her
I've only talked to her husband okay and
we kind of f because we both do gear
okay
um [__] what was I what was I going to
say what we talking about before that um
[__] about how it wasn't like um the
whole thing about just [__] random
dudes and [__] like that oh um [__] yeah
I forgot where I was going with it
though I've been drinking they're
um this kind of like people in the
circus yeah you know which yeah I get it
is kind of like a carnival yeah oh what
I saying what I saying their situation
was they make all this video right but
actually when you look at the numbers
that's not where the money's coming from
the money's coming from all the live
streaming stuff
yeah she [__] makes [__] 200
almost $300 a day doing three hours a
day at
streaming and a lot of it is because she
has [__] 50 60,000
followers on that platform but that all
came from the porn the porn is kind of
like an advertisement yeah the porn
makes money but that's you need to make
a lot of it to add up to do anything and
they've been doing it for a long time so
there's a lot of it out there and it's
just like us when we did the videos for
13 o'clock over time man there's so many
shows that You' forgotten them we're
doing that with porn seeds yeah that
stuff stays out in cyberspace acting as
like a [__]
advertisement and It All Leads back to
their Twitter and on the Twitter it goes
it eventually goes to a link tree that
has everywhere where she's performing
and and uh and her streammate and her um
with only
fans that's on there too yeah and it all
adds up but the main bulk of it is
stream
mate and that's kind
of with porn not with with with these
porn stars Studio porn stars like say
Angela White and [__] um this is you
already know this I'm just telling the
The
Listener the the the the
porn they get paid just once for every
time they do the scene they don't own
the material after that unless they
unless they own it and they did it
themselves and they have it out there on
uh only fans or something they own that
but the [__] that went to the studio for
porn they don't own that they don't make
much money on it they might get $1,000
on that one day
maybe top girl probably would about a
th000 that's really nothing compared to
what they're used to what they want to
make most of those porn stars their real
money is [__] made [__]
escorting escorting or sugaring which is
you have sugar
daddies so um and you can find them you
can find all their escort stuff that's
really where they're just using the
studio porn as a justif as an
advertisement and a justification for
hiking up
their um escorting fees yeah
because what they really want is they
want somebody to fly them out to a
location for a couple days and spend two
or three days with some dude who's some
kind of C CEO
or maybe a politician or a dude from
[__] Saudi Arabia or something you
know
[__] what's that other one not c not
cutter but [__]
Dubai and spend [__] 30,000 on them
in three days that that's really what
they're looking
for because I got dudes that will spend
that yeah I think it's simpy as [__] I
never spent $30,000 on some chick
[__] like that three
days but the thing is is that I'm
looking at it through the eyes of a dude
that doesn't make all that much
money those guys is so rich 30,000 is
nothing that's like me dropping down 30
or 40 bucks yeah you know they'll fly
her down there and everything and you
probably pay for a 30 or $40 hooker
right well yeah if you weren't available
no I'm was
kidding yeah if I was out of town or
something I had before up in Korea uh
but it's just a different situation you
know what I mean [__] those dudes are
real rich and [__] he'll fly down in
his [__] yeah it's not really a big
deal for that and yeah and he's like
yeah she'll be here tomorrow like it
seems like a big deal to us because we
don't have any money but yeah but to
that to that dude it's not a big deal
and yeah she'll be over at the compound
he flies her into a little compound you
know his wife's at another compound or
his wife doesn't give a [__] what he's
doing you know she's doing whatever she
wants to do too probably well hopefully
and he's a oh yeah if he is oh yeah oh
yeah Fair as Fair usually usually like I
said before usually the only thing those
dudes care about is don't get pregnant
you know that's usually what well she
probably doesn't want to get pregnant
either yeah they're talking talk about
when you were asking about um gay for
pay you asked Victor about it yeah
Victor says it's a spectrum some
straight dudes are down to get blown by
a dude every now and then some would
never do it okay that's kind of how I
felt about it too that's not exactly
what this one dude was doing that I was
talking about it was kind of like BDSM
and humiliation of twinks roughing them
up yeah but also
like straight off diving in diving off
into the dude and [__] you know ATM
[__] if you know what I'm talking about
asy mouth [__] and [__] just roughing
them
up and uh he was selling it only fans
type stuff and here's the weird thing
there was a [__] element of damn
Financial domination you know he's
[__] jacked that's kind of a big
thing yeah he's jacked he's [__] good
looking dude [__]
bodybuilder those twinks were paying him
to to be in those
movies he wasn't paying them to be in
his movie they were paying him to be in
a
movie ain't that some [__] and that and
the and and evidently the [__]
exchanging of the money the payment all
right is in the
video so there's like Financial
domination that's that's kind of a big
thing we have like one person that comes
in our yeah room sometimes on streamate
who's a sub and if you like all you have
to do is yell at them to like give you a
tip and they will
yeah yeah which is like well that other
guy that was just sitting there he was
all the other one just tipped you uh but
I we sweet talked him into [__] tip
and so you be a good boy you go ahead
and give her a
tip and then every time he gave her a
tip [__] I said okay I'll tell you
what for a reward I'm going to give you
a little [__] sneak peek and I just
[__] tease him with parts of Jenny
and [__] different shots and [__] [__]
he didn't hardly get anything though
well no it was just cuz you don't want
to give him too much and then then all
of a sudden you look like a cheap [__]
it's got to be hard for a s to get
together that's the game that those
dudes want to
play but but anyway the dude I was
talking
about the [__] I was doing was [__] I
was [__] he was
doing
no I don't think a straight dude could
do it
well I guess he just I guess it depends
on the I think he was just kind of
pretending to be straight or was mostly
straight he had a girlfriend yeah but he
was interested in other things too I
think he was
by nothing wrong with that I think he
was by byy on the sly but he he was
pretended to be gay he was pretending to
be gay for pay but he was byy on the sly
see that's a good [__] I just wrote
that [__] right now although the gays
probably hit beat me to it they probably
have that one yeah I kind of imagine
that I mean that's it's laying right
there I don't really know laying right
there right I wouldn't I wouldn't
imagine somebody would have picked that
up said he's gay for pay but he's byy on
a
Sly yeah DVD Dragon says Tom what did
you think of the build of the natural
Fitness celebrity liver King dude got
popped for using 12K a month of steroids
with his sixpack and implant you know
about I've heard of that dude but I
don't remember King liver King I didn't
never see any of his videos all right I
got to pee you what you talk all right I
never saw liver King's videos or
anything I saw other videos of people
talking about liver King they would just
show that dude and he have a raw liver
in his hand like he's eating it I don't
really know why they called him liver
King I know that I guess he ate raw
liver I don't know if he was saying that
eating raw liver makes you big but no as
soon as I see the dude I said man he's
[__] jacked to the gills on [__]
gear as old as he is he was in his
looked like his 40s or 50s you can't
have that [__] can build naturally
just by working out at that age [__]
tripping [__]
tripping best Natty I saw me personally
with my own eyes recently and Jen was
with me we went to PetSmart to go pick
up some cat treats or something this is
at the at the mall out near that Chinese
restaurant we go
to and [__] dude we were waiting in
line and [__] one of the cashiers
goes over here man I got you and I turn
look and it was a Gym Bro man [__] at
the checkout and and he's goes how you
doing man I dude you looking [__]
jacked and he's like oh you're looking
good and it turned out he was only 18
years old 18 years old and he was
looking good and and I go I said are you
on geared he goes no not let I says I
can't wait to go on gear and I says when
you going to go on he goes when I'm 25
I'm gonna go on gear and I says no dude
that's that's that's a little early I
said [__] you need to go on like more
like 35 and he goes no I'm gonna go on
at 25 I just like okay which okay you
know dke could do what he wants if I see
him again I'm GNA [__] amend my
advice you can go on that early if you
want to but you have to understand as a
young guy if you start [__] around
with injecting test at 25 you're going
to be on that for
Life yeah you can come off but you won't
want to it's kind of addictive you know
you take it you go man I feel great then
you start seeing all these results and
you go yeah this is this is the way to
go
and then do it get get around all those
[__] side effects of higher doses of
test because you start raising the test
up you say well [__] it I'm going to
lower the test down and put it in
steroids anabolic steroids because
anabolic steroids it is test it's just
been the car the carbon molecules on it
have been moved around on that mole the
carbon atoms have been moved around on
that molecule to alleviate the side
effects of high levels of testosterone
so it's like test that you can take more
of really it's actually safer than test
uh as long as you know what you're doing
uh none of that [__] stand alone it's
all going to be done in his
St so what I was reason why I told the
story is I said the best natties I've
seen were [__] late teens early
20s because a guy at that age man if
he's got decent genetics producing a lot
of
testosterone especially if you're
working out and you're eating right
because your body will make more Jenny
remembers him you remember the guy I was
talking about yeah no I don't cuz I was
just we at smart that petmart going
through the checkout I said the best
Natty I've seen recently with my own
eyes was about 18 I was in the bathroom
CU so I didn't hear the first part yeah
cuz he was he was young yeah whenever
you see a dude over the age of 30 who's
just [__]
shredded lot of Mass on him okay and
he's got a very
low you know body fat
percentages he's like 15% and Below
sometimes even 20% and Below but usually
around 15 he's on [__] if he's over 35
yeah unless he's got fantastic genetics
and there's very few people that are
like that and usually if he's got
fantastic genetics to keep weight off in
the age he's not massive he's
skinny they got some people that just
have a real thin build they're like a I
think they're called ectomorphs and they
just have a thin build and they could
like um what's his
name our friend from the club old guy
skinny as [__] who Mark Mark I don't
think you could put weight on Mark but
Mark's going to look like a
skeleton if you see a dude that has a
bunch of meat on him and there's no fat
that's [__] gear
man especially over the age of 35 so no
[__] liver King didn't fool me not
one bit Camp guy says free internet porn
is normal today but would be considered
totally debauched in today in
yesterday's Society I don't even care
who sees my internet history or download
back Trail anymore yeah yesterday's
Society my grandmother and grandpappy
would think we were totally Beyond out
there they would have a
coronary probably probably they were
probably doing [__] up [__] to you but
I guess it wasn't like acceptable to
talk about back then wasn't mainstreamed
they now everybody just talks about
whatever and it's just I think it's a
lot better nowadays yeah like people
just talk about like whatever and people
are just like yeah okay
but back in the early 1900s [__] you
had guys like Albert Fish running around
who's doing fu [__] just bizarre [__]
to children and people and what was that
18 what or 19 I mean well yeah but I
mean you can't really compare that to
well I guess you kind of can because
it's all on a spectum you had people
doing yeah there were people doing
freaky [__] it's just they didn't like
people didn't talk about like it wasn't
acceptable to talk about which in a lot
of ways I think is probably unhealthy
yeah cuz you end up with dudes like
Albert Fish I think cuz that's kind of
yeah that's kind of where I'm at cuz
we've talked about this a lot too it's
like how many serial killers would have
turned out okay if they had grown up in
a time where it wasn't unacceptable to
like talk about like weird sexual
fetishes and stuff like nowadays like
you can talk about hey I have a fetish
for blahy blah and everybody's like hey
me too and it's just like there's a
whole [__] Reddit for him to like
talk about it cannibalism that's what I
mean and it's like if you had that if
they had that like maybe they wouldn't
have had to act on it in real life yeah
so they kind of blow off steam on the
internet just fantasizing about it and
then they know there's a bunch of them
out there and they never actually have
to do it
yeah the guy was on his own it's
healthier if the dude was on his own and
didn't know that there's a lot of people
that have that he'd probably think man
I'm [__] must be a monster man so I'm
so I'm gonna go ahead and eat somebody
yeah I think that's exactly what happens
I think that's what they because like
and even people with like just normal
ass like what we would consider like
normal ass fetishes you know what I mean
like even back in the old days when like
even something as vanilla is like BDSM
or something like that was like pretty
scandalous so it's like even if you were
like into that but you didn't know
anybody else that was into that you
probably thought you were like the
biggest Freakazoid ever and it's like
that would isolate you even further
which I don't think is like super
healthy I think it's like much better to
think it's like oh hey there's other
people that are into that and as long as
everybody's consenting then it's all
good and another thing is is that you're
only seeing things now because of the
internet and you're looking at it in a
certain way and it yeah it's become very
mainstreamed but that's happened many
times in history Europe in the [__]
20s and the 30s was [__] wild uh
there was [__] that was happening in
vinar Republic Germany it was just
unspeakable you know [__] child
prostitution and everything and it was
pretty mainstream they knew about it um
you could go to a BDSM Club in [__]
Berlin and watch lesbians spank school
boys you know what I mean [__] like that
you know and weird [__] was happen you
could go to certain streets in Germany
and uh see mother daughter underage
daughter mother underage daughter
[__] prostitution couples in other
words you could have the mom and the
daughter you could they had whole
streets that had what was called
crickets or grasshoppers which were the
ugliest women possible uh hunchbacks
deformed they had dudes that were going
down sporting them they were like let's
go to let's go uh screw the worst women
possible and that was like a challenge
you know it was just and they paid them
and I think they weren't didn't cost
much there was just so there's all kinds
of [__] that went on in history Rome was
pretty [__] up all right that involved
basically snuff porn some of that [__]
that they were doing in the Coliseum
they were killing prisoners and mock
battle reenactments and [__] okay let's
not do that but I'm just saying that was
basically almost like snuff porn well
yeah that's what I mean let's not do
snor yeah they were doing [__] like that
uh evidently they did have things that
were like horn in the Coliseum at
certain times where uh acrobats and then
dancers and then sexual performers and
some of the [__] like included from what
I remember beastiality women and Bulls
that kind of [__] right
um whether or not they actually
copulated or just simulated it I they
kind of think they probably simulated it
you can't depend on well I mean a show
yeah a show is Show's a show like I'm
sure sometimes they were like okay we
can do this and sometimes they're like
well okay we can't do so let just safest
the safest thing to do to get that show
something like that done thinking about
it today that bull probably had a strap
on probably yeah yeah they probably had
har probably had a harness on the bull
to kind of H hide the fact that it had a
strap on cuz how could you depend on
that bull to [__]
perform it's probably just a strap on a
fake dick [__] they were just
pretending yeah probably like I said
that would be you know it's just a show
they did creepy [__] or not creepy [__]
that's just kinky [__] they did did
Kinky
[__] going way back the uh the Aztec did
creepy [__]
by and freaky [__] uh necrophilia was
one of the things and that's still going
on between yeah which still going on in
in Mexico with the drug cartels there
was a gang of satanic witch females in
in a had a drug cartel they were they
were assassins and to join their little
witches coven they worked for other
cartels they [__] seducing dudes and
killing them for
hire to join the club yet they had to
have sex with like one of the Dead
victims and [__] was in a bathtub like
countless bathy [__] evently they were
hot um hot dead people no they were hot
[__] chicks oh uh that were
assassins and uh their whole thing was
is just pick dudes up in bars and take
them to a location and assassinate them
it was like for higher you know they
were being targeted by client but to
join them you had to
have sex with one of the [__] victims
dead body and [__] here's the thing like
I don't know like because Mr 's talking
about like some things being a step too
far and obviously like yeah snuff born
yeah no let's not do that I'm not really
and I know that it's legal in some
countries I'm not a huge fan of like the
beastiality thing just because well I
don't know that's kind of a gray area
because a lot of times well the animals
can't consent but like in some videos it
looks like the animal is into it and
they weren't forced into it yeah so it's
just kind of like dog jumping on a girl
and she's yeah and it's just kind of
like well yeah I don't know maybe that's
all right but and then the weird thing
about
necrofilia is that well there's not
really consent involved because the
person's dead right but it's still kind
of gross it's desecration of a dead body
yeah I mean it's still pretty yeah
that's terrible I me [__] you know
and even though I'm not religious so I
don't have a religious objection to it
I'm just saying I just think it's kind
of well the rumors of that kind of [__]
at least in in when you talk about morgs
and the rumors are always centered
centered
around children the bodies of children
right or very beautiful young women you
know being abused that's you know that's
the body of somebody's dead LED one yeah
that's what I mean it's like that kind
of bothers me more than like I said it's
not a religious thing it's just kind of
like hey that's somebody's relative
let's not funeral hasn't even happened
yet that's kind of
disrespectful you know what I mean yeah
that's like I said if that person was
alive they probably would not be down
with it now in so in Old Time Mexico
during the Aztec era you know the Mayans
did [__] like they'd had mummified Kings
right and they'd [__] have them in
certain corners and certain places in
the temple and they're bringing that
King food and [__] weapons and [__]
and sending women to him to like have
sex with him now I don't like godamn it
I don't know how they did that it must
have on the necrofilia details great it
must have been like a strap on
on on the mummy it's a mummy yeah you
know gotta go [__] the mummy on the
right
backy so but you know oh man maybe we
maybe we should get a mummy sex though
yeah that would be that would be like
ritual that would be like ritual
religious right which is but it's still
that's still weird still necrophilia
sorry you're making sure the king is
happy yeah I don't care what
justification you come up with for it
it's still [__] gross you know what I
mean yeah like [__] it was got to go
[__] the mmy
probably knowing knowing that knowing
the old Mexican system it was probably
like a priestess that had to do it
something like oh I imagine there
probably something religious
yeah they had a ration out for it though
you know just like helping the king out
in the afterworld that type of [__] yeah
like I said but you can come up with any
kind of weird convoluted justification
for you want it's still [__] gross
well I don't think it was deception I
think they believed it I think oh I'm
sure they did they believed it they
believed that that there was in the but
it's still that [__] not real so it's
just like that's not a they believe the
king had to be kept satisfied in the
afterlife sorry the dude's dead yeah
like let's not yeah it's a sacrifice
Victor says you can whip out the Ouija
board and get yeah yeah yeah it said yes
there you go yeah yeah yeah would you
like to get [__] right now yes yeah
yes Danny Rowling said it was actually
you guys maybe don't know this but my
mouse pad is a Ouija
board I've been using it like this whole
en Danny ring said there was a female
morg worker I remember hearing about
this that would bang the dead males and
even kidnapped a corpse during their
funeral just to bang it and the family
was wondering where she went with their
family members yeah I kind of remember
hearing about that game maybe we should
do a show about that how did he get
erected put she put a [__] uh St did
she inject something in there or like
put a put a no there'd be no response or
well no like maybe I I I don't know it
somehow well yeah like I've never worked
in a morg but maybe do they have like
some kind of little things they can like
stick in your body to like keep it from
uh you know collapsing at certain I
don't know points I don't know Bryce
says animals and dead bodies like kids
and family are off limits to me that
[__] is gross I mean yeah it it is kind
of gross it is kind of
gross yeah Sammy said wouldn't you want
Grandpa to get a little before they put
him in the ground
LOL
I mean you know you don't know how long
it's been
since Maggie Max says #d do not [__]
mommy
yeah I mean like I said maybe we should
get a sex doll looks like people are
weird man they are weird and it's just
kind of like and people think we're
weird we're not that weird but yeah but
the sex doll thing sex dolls aren't
weird really no I don't think sex dolls
are weird it's an inanimate object it's
an inanimate object it looks like a
person kind of but it's just yeah it's
just like I said it's like a dild though
except it's like built out right kind of
if you get one if if we get one we're
going to get a good one one that looks
good on camera it's going to be fantasy
based so it's not so man I just don't
like the ones that are too realistic
they just look too much like corse look
too much like a corpse to me yeah it's
like having a dead body in your house
you have to like stuff her in the closet
or something like that I want something
that look like a damn something out of
World of Warcraft and like I said I'm
even more weirded out by just like the
the male torsos with the dick on them
I'm just like okay
and I know I've watched like some videos
with like girls with those but it's just
like I don't know they're just they're
weird to me see we see if we can get one
that can be converted into like a Kuda
and [__] like that and you can [__]
around with that I want one that's like
modular yeah we'll see we'll see what
they have and how much it
costs I mean I just thought that would
be a good it has to look like an anime
character yeah like I mean yeah this
might be something like down the line
that we might want to like look at
investing in just for more options once
CE once the money situation gets better
and pay off of a little bit of debt
[__] uh I know I know Amazon will
give me the credit for it they basically
told me that yeah you can get it when I
was looking at them I saw how much they
how much it was a month right and it it
was kind of and implied I was
pre-approved for it because it knows my
credit score I got a good credit score
what are you doing Pokey I she's she's
going with to town on the books over
there don't tear the books up she's like
oh I'm going to do it uhuh look she
she's yeah you're talking you know what
it is we've been on the show too long
she's pulling all the books out what are
you doing she's pulling all the books
out of them she run away
screaming I'm in trouble yeah come here
she's like she like no come here she's
pulling all the books out of the [__]
she knows when she's in trouble the
bookshelf she like no dadd she pulled
out rose red and like uh F and like a
couple of other books that were down
there she's pulling them all out she's
it's 11 okay and I got that lasna
sitting down there in the oven oh [__] I
forgot yeah you were cooking some food
down there yeah I had it on a timer it's
just sitting there it's good to go all
right maybe we should it's Friday night
I guess should eggplant lasna eggplant
lasagna oh and then she pulled out
whatever the Martian Chronicles she's
pulling out all the books down there all
right so we're going to wrap it up we're
going to go eat some lasagna maybe watch
some videos then go to sleep because
it's Friday night and we're not going
any place so um Danny says where's that
raccoon all right we'll do it okay hold
on I got to find it where is it it's
still I got to be there it's got to be
there somewhere where is that raccoon I
thought I put it at the bottom it's got
to still be here I did not take it out
oh maybe I did oh there it is where is
that raccoon there it is I KN I was like
I know I didn't remove it it's still in
here somewhere um but yeah Mr said love
y'all oh that's nice all right so we're
going to wrap it up have a good weekend
you guys we will be back again on Monday
night uh doing a movie review I don't
know what movie it's going to be because
we haven't watched one yet so we'll find
out when you will so that should be fun
but yeah thanks for dropping by thanks
for super chats thanks for this very
scintilating conversation about all
kinds of stuff sex dolls and whatnot and
we'll see you guys again on Monday
goodby